see my rook I've been setting you up
this whole time baby then why am I still
single and the biggest strongest event
and online chess is back for another
year with a matchup that I don't think
there would be any better way to start
this season than to have two players of
this caliber and this experience in this
format kicking things off with me Grand
Master Robert Hess Robert the players
are here they're ready they're they're
zoned in who you got in this match well
I'm gonna have to check my bracket cuz I
just filled one out yesterday but I
think I picked Fabiano with the upset
and this one you know I got to give my
respect to Levon he's an amazing player
but with everyone counting Fabi out I
just had to give him his fair do well as
Robert just mentioned according to our
stats and the fact that both of these
guys have played a lot of chess on our
site and a lot of chess in this format
we were able to kind of dive into the
numbers there and as you can see
according to our odds based on the time
controls Levon is a slight favorite but
I'm with you that I think this is very
close to a coin flip I'm also gonna say
that from a practical perspective I
would have a hard time picking against
Fabiano given that he he is so active on
chest comm he spent a lot of time on the
site yesterday while John Herschel and I
were having fun solving puzzles he was
busy beating up on unstable x' like
Yaakov Yaakov and others did you jump in
in the in the Fabiano let him let him
beat you down games yesterday if I had
known he was playing I would have given
him a little bit of heartbreak before
his yeah match today but I didn't see
that he was playing but it's good to get
that practice in because of course we've
seen him go down he's won in two
lifetime record and speech Chess
Championship and for LaVon he's looking
to get his first victory so I think that
Bobby's ready to keep him at a winless
start well LaVon is just slightly off
camera right now but for those paying
close attention can see that he is
sporting a Celtics jersey we can confirm
that it's Al Horford for those big
Horford fans we'll talk to LaVon a
little bit about the shake-up in the NBA
east after the match but let's bring up
those stats just as we discuss
right here we have the numbers these
guys their lifetime record in the SCC as
Robert said LaVon that are very unlucky
Owen - to be perfectly honest he had one
of the most thrilling matches ever in
the first year I think you and I
remembered the match against grishnack
very well right it was so close yep and
then last year he lost a heartbreaker to
Nepal moyashi partly chess comm to blame
given that there was some confusion on
the rules and some connection issues so
I'll go ahead and fall on my sword for
that one and say that it's about as
strong of an O and two is I think you
could have and then you have Fabiana
right who has also he's 1 & 2 he BEF on
who you fought handily in last year's
first-round matchup but has struggled to
get to get past that so far beyond that
the bracket this year for those of you
who somehow are familiar with what the
SEC is those are all the players remind
you that Hikaru and Yifan will be
playing on Thursday so not too much from
now but ok to keep focused on this
specific matchup that's starting right
away actually let's let's talk a little
bit about the overall odds you said you
filled out your fantasy bracket Robert
we've got all these odds here that put
put these guys overall chances to win it
along with all the other players have
you I've been paying too much attention
to that based on their stats you know I
looked at the stats I kind of shrugged
it off because I'm a March Madness fan I
love it filling out my bracket and you
can't always go with the team that's
expected when some guys are gonna vote
for the underdog alright well regardless
of the odds let's remind everybody what
the format is it's gonna be three hours
of non-stop action though the overall
season format is single elimination so
these players are always playing for
their life and right to move on it is 16
players and three time controls will go
down over the next three hours 90
minutes of five-minute blitz 60 minutes
of three minutes until finally the half
an hour with bullet the great equalizer
prizes on the line start small and get
bigger really as as every round moving
on gets bigger and bigger for these
players and of course we're building up
to the ultimate showdown the final four
off all of the final two matches the
semifinals and the finals will take
place December 1st and 2nd and so we're
going to start things off and find out
which of these 16 chef superstars will
be there so on that note and thank you
there we have a our first donation to
which sub of the day let's
let's move back to our players and get
this show on the road Robert were two
minutes past the hour I think it's time
time for these guys to throw down yep
absolutely nice see if Fabiana gets the
white pieces in the first game and
Knight f3 a little bit of a surprise
would you say Danny considering he's
such a consistent Eve for Blair yeah
Fabiano joked with us before this match
started this morning that he had been
doing prep specifically for the Vaughn I
think because most people know he's
doing prep for Magnus right now it was
sort of a poking at LaVon but who knows
maybe he did come up with something
special for the mesh that was pretty
funny he had the magazine cover with
lavon's face on it yeah look I've been
preparing for you and of course LaVon
it's typical style ribbing taking jabs
at Fabi and us we're not in we're not
free from the LaVon jokes and here we
see Fabio the devil fianchetto set up
which in the first game pretty calm but
what's wise LaVon spending so much time
here that's what I wanted man well maybe
he's trying to recall the the setup he
likes best obviously this isn't
something they face every day in terms
of high-level preparation right if these
two were playing it in a classical
tournament I don't think this would be
thought beyond his choice no absolutely
not that's for sure and if Magnus is
watching after his game and Bill today I
don't think he's going to be expecting
this in their matchup either but I like
this choice for Fabi you get the two
bishops right now you can play g4
exactly and business does this not
remind you of some of the some of the
games we saw when LaVon played in a pom
Miyoshi Nippo consistently sported both
a London and ready type set up and I
feel like we've seen this sort of idea
where the knight moves from f6 to
unleash the bishop hitting the knight on
the edge of the board before yeah
absolutely and you know it's not lavon's
first rodeo he's very well experienced
in these types of positions and that's
that 9 ft 7 move that cait's that night
on h4 but once the knight comes back to
f3 and you see father played d4 here
white is more space I think a slightly
more comfortable position the knight on
a 6 doesn't have a the greatest future
but if I'm black you know you're
considering making the move c5 but when
you make a move like that you're always
concerned can a knight get to the B 5
square is there any way for white to
take advantage of that pawn push and
here where I can play e4
before happens right away gaining more
space trying to win these bishops so I'm
liking White's position and the time
advantage those bar yeah quick trade on
e4 though black not interested I think
and white getting a further further pawn
push like a five okay but now the
question is I was gonna say does he
retreat the bishop or be willing to part
with the bishop pair and if you're white
you know maybe don't really want to take
it if black comes out and quickly gets
access to these dark squares
specifically be the knight coming in to
f4 right yeah so he says no thank you
yeah that's a great lesson for people
watching is that you don't necessarily
come and take it you have to also make
sure it's taken care of your weaknesses
as well so I find Queen e2 you make
certain the Knights not come to have
four right right yet and now move like
c4 is very tempting for white but then
you could think well it might be defog
to be six happens am I is my pawn
structure being undermined and so I'll
have to do something about my b3 pawn my
c4 pawn and you don't really you want to
move c5 to solidify your control of d6
square but it also permanently gives
black that d5 square and return he's
actually going for it right now oh yeah
c5 take over the d6 square but give up
this d5 square for the rest I was gonna
say is are we sure he's gonna play see I
guess he will know I was gonna okay if
he doesn't after takes now if Queen
takes there's d5 and if Knight takes
maybe he sits on the structure something
like Queen de beat c3 or Queen before
okay 95 another way to defend the c4
pawn because my point is that this pawn
might be able to be gathered the
old-fashioned way and and if I can keep
these two center plants together rather
than having to play c5 and give up the
square I'd be happy yeah and I could
definitely use an old fashioned after
getting that verbal beatdown from LaVon
there but yeah you can just go and
gather this b3 problem we're gonna ship
C to Dan yeah that would be an
interesting interesting way to to try to
hold on to just the pawn but may be
worth it yeah cuz you can go Queen
before and go after the b7 pawn but I'm
just worried that this move Bishop c2
comes in if I take on g6 right now black
takes back with the H bond and he played
Queen before first a bishop c2 here if I
go c5 then black can make them of Knight
to a4 and it's kind of uncomfortable for
both sides but this I like that move a
for we're getting the line that we
talked about though right black is
deciding it's worth it to hold on
spawn and whites saying well I like
keeping all my pawns together and now
I'm gonna try to just use a space
advantage on the on the queenside yeah
if you protect your b7 pawn now so
there's two ways to do that rook a7 and
the point over k7 is that you can slide
the Queen to a behind it but I'm worried
about a five a six right if I just play
a five eight your Knight mb6
I play a six undermine your protection
of the c6 pawn so that's certainly
something to worry about if I like Queen
c7 well white can still play a five and
gather more space but then I can
retrieve my Knight to d7 offering us
traded the Knights so he won't work a7
he's he likes the fact that he can
double in the a file after a5 he'll go
Knight to d7 offering in exchange of
those Knights but I'm still I mean I
really feel like 85 86 just coming steam
ahead
a5 a6 undermine the protection of the c6
pawn everybody even trading on e5
doesn't really help getting rid of that
night because you still have this Bishop
hitting the pawn here and we can we can
see that analysis they're favoring white
especially if we can break through win
to c6 pawn and keep the c4 pawn that's
gonna be a passer at some point I it's
Fabiano okay he goes a5 I wonder if he's
considering any other tactics on c6
something with no reason to go for
things like Bishop takes Knight takes
and fork the Queen and rook because as
you said a6 does the all the undermining
that white needs here and I think black
can try this much c5 I don't know if it
actually helps but see if I can just
take it but yeah just take with the pawn
my 95 still defended then I have a to
patsy pawns there were HAP's people in
New York who try being kinder drivers to
each other huh yeah that sounded like a
little truck honking were there did like
somebody was you know somebody it was
off to the wrong foot this morning
okay Queen c8 so black is gonna try to
take on b7 with the rook everyone gained
a tempo on the Queen and maybe then try
to protect the C pawn although even if
you do that the Queen comes back to c3
you can't place c5 because the bishop on
on Jeju hits b7 so I still like White's
pressure and okay the one saving grace a
at this point but let's not forget LaVon
is up a pawn at this exact moment
despite White's pressure so if he can
swindle his way defending the Queen side
maybe this b3 pawn has something to say
before it's all done
look at the time LaVon now now ahead on
the clock Robert after starting out way
ahead yeah but I was about to say this
line with the Queen coming in d6 because
now the c6 pawn cannot be defend if you
take on e5 I simply take back with the
pawn I win your c6 pawn though I will
say that this Bishop C to pawn b3
configuration yeah it's very neat for
black in the endgame because if we'd
Spade Queens then it's gonna be very
hard to actually Corral that pawned
yeah and then the knight can be very
annoying coming let's say through c5
it's a d3 so yep and sometimes the
potential of a pond like this everybody
isn't just about whether you see a
forcing way to punch it through as
obviously right now you can't but just
the fact that it ties White's pieces
down the fact that white constantly has
to worry about moving this dark square
Bishop anywhere because of b2 b1 so when
you're evaluating a transition in the
endgame you want to have the long term
goals in mind and the fact that this B
pond is kind of crippling to White's
Queen side plans is one of the useful
things about it even though it is
blockaded right now in this position
Bishop takes c6 looks like a great move
and the point is that I'm hitting rook
and Knight if you look at c7 the only
way to keep both I was gonna rook a8 but
then you had this move Knight b8 retreat
I think it's the only way to not lose
material so that was a pretty
interesting transition right there Bobby
declines taking with the bishop though
decides to trade with the Queen perhaps
you were right though perhaps Bishop
takes would have been would have been
the stronger approach he likes getting
the Queens off the board though maybe he
feels his C pawn has more potential to
march than than blacks blockaded B pawn
but now what would stop rook takes c4
rook c4 rook e8 Knight b8 where is
Fabiano's next move yeah he goes for it
I'm not sure is there something with
Bishop a3 hitting the rook on f8 at some
point I just like blacks position
honestly doesn't budge rikiei just came
in and so you can't sacrifice your queen
for the rook because you lose your
knight nd7 at the end so that's okiya
Queen c7 just move up 8f fates protected
hmm defending well black really is I
mean given that white a ton of pressure
but I'm gonna I'm gonna go on a limb and
say that Fabiano underestimated your
bishop takes c6 Robert and that's what
he should have done yeah I think so
and here okay it's still very tricky
especially the only one minute and 15
seconds of counting down for both sides
you take on d6 you give a pawn on the
sixth rank and then the King on Jade
still needs to create left then the a1
rope can come to a 7 and try to kick
this knight from the d7 square so it's
not a simple position by any means in
order for black to make progress you're
gonna have to a ward off White's threats
and then B move your bishop away from
the c2 square yeah in order to try to
get the Brook there yeah I uh
yeah I'm still in the boat that I like
Fabiano's position 2 despite the maybe
the miss Bishop takes c6 but but now how
do how does he make progress I guess the
main thing too is just like I said about
the b-pawn we could say about the deep
on it's not even whether you have a
concrete win right now this is a very
dangerous pawn just because it keeps
blacks Knights stuck on d7 there's
constant threats along the back rank
right now and LaVon only has 30 seconds
to figure it out so can you just take on
e4 take one more take and then broke a7
no but they're brookey's em is no threat
because then you can't capture the night
with your brook I made aa C so he trades
first now he's probably gonna play brook
a8 to threaten d7 d7 first you go d7 95
d7 Knight takes rook a a check and then
Bishop a3 at the end of the line
everybody Roberts saw it faster than
Fabiano did and I'm gonna show you on
the analysis board what's coming nope I
can't move them as fast as they are and
I think this is gonna be the first win
in the books for Fabiano kh6 you win the
f8 night it's not okay he plays h5 it's
not just over yet only because it splits
right but there's also a few pawns
remaining for white so you're gonna take
on g4 if you take on h5 black goes rook
a for kicking out and if you try to
defend g4 first this rooks gonna come
down and make threats on the b-pawn well
I look up seven okay that's good cuz
after work a4 Bishop g7 there's the
attack on the g7 pawn really and was a
b2 would have worked there I think
you're where rook a for Bishop f8 b 2
you know
should be - don't go fade okay I
thought you said Bishop f8 I'm sorry no
ok so takes takes chief for now but yeah
like you said there's not a lot of pawns
for white and in over the board game we
would definitely say White's gonna win
this no way he's not gonna be able to
hold on to the F pawn and Corral all of
these pawns but who knows and blitz
whether Fabiana will have as good a
technique yes Bishop b2 here you okay -
yep you're gonna Bishop d4 I think might
be the precise move right take on g7
actually but I was worried about the F
losing the F to pawn bishop takes g7
King g6 yeah I agree
so playing bishop d4 first exactly but
this will need three push of rook
on b7 Bellbrook c2 though and as King g3
works okay Bishop d4 now Bishop b4 is
gonna corral this pawn both take them
you take on g7 here or take on b2 right
away it doesn't matter and Ricky - or a
p5 check yeah this is easy now yep at
this point white can centralize
everything f4 put the bishop on a
protected square relocate the King
around and eventually start ganging up
on one or two of these pawns no way
black and defend that's an active King
that is an active King my favorite type
of King and with it comes the
resignation and the first the first game
in the books right there Lee Prince
coming through with the cheer thank you
so much for the support I haven't given
much love to the chat here well we do
see our first spamming of the the
Fatheads if you are not a subscriber to
our chess channel you should do so
during this match and show your love for
whoever you're rooting for whether that
be
Fabiano or LaVon you can you can do just
that by you know letting them know spam
a Fathead I always say when in doubt
spam Fatheads and I had to give Tommy
Shelby shut up because he said LaVon in
the basement of a bar which is hilarious
right
yeah the ceiling lighting does look a
little a little bar basement he Oh Baba
blame the French so he used to be
difficult to pin down today he's fine I
know plus he's playing the French is he
like trying to send a message to me and
you that the French isn't as bad as
previously
rumors of rumors of the demise are
greatly overrated of the French
apparently well we did see Dominguez
destroy the French game after game
against your admirer and then we saw
young De Palma she crushed Meyer well
well I won't say crushed baby great
ideas in a French in the recently
concluded Dortmund so yeah the French
has seen better days and from fabi's
point of view he's also the French
crusher he beat both Alec Slenderman and
vara Cobian in the US Championship on
the white side of the French and I
already don't know he's moving his
pieces backward LaVon typically not an
e4 player at least not over the board
but he's going straight for the king now
in the age 5 threatens the g7 square he
played a night at 5 which of course
makes sense you did to protect the g7
pawn and it's not so easy for white to
make progress especially without a light
square Bishop to play move like Bishop
d3 to attack the men f5 and so the night
of 5 sits there for a while protects g7
ok Bishop g5 click Queen e8 now and your
queen now can actually swing over to the
a4 or see 6 squares even d5 and maybe
create some problems there but wait has
it's hard not to look at these positions
and just feel great about white but I
have a confession about the French yes I
played against it in my first over the
board tournament and and it would quite
sometime this weekend and I did not win
I didn't lose but I did not win that's a
loss not beating a friend you know what
I can't disagree with you as as John has
reminded me of several times since that
day but you know what maybe Fabiana will
will bring justice to all those who know
the French is lost
wait he's black well he's playing this
very actively from the black side
because he's suggesting that White's
pressure on the King side is not going
to be sustainable but this is why Queen
d1 is a nice lucky move
obviously you're protecting the c2 pond
but now you can go G for f4 f5 and near
future and what black 7 to take care of
the f6 square see he can play g6 himself
yeah shout-out to Fe who just subscribed
thank you for that all the support
seriously everybody about 2000 of you
with us now we think that's going to
grow throughout the day thanks for being
here at the first B Chess Championship
match and thanks for your support with
you
all of these amazing events happen and
hopefully it's gonna be a great year
although again okay so I'm I'm hoping
this is the last French we see because
LaVon orchestrates what we're begging
for with f5 and white ends up with a
massive attack against the king what do
you thinking he just went King e8
shaking try to Castle queenside yeah
that's literally the king running away
from his fate he knows that there's
problems coming so let's see if your
black hair do you want to take tight you
don't want is strong but do you take
twisting f5 and hope that your position
doesn't collapse on Knight of fate well
he's holding I guess again from the
perspective that let's not assume the
French is lost until it is lost so I
mean a3 here for Queen of three Queen
take C to F takes F takes yeah I can I
can take the bishop in and I'm actually
getting out I think maybe you want to
play move like rook F to first just a
and useful both defensive move over the
sea to pawn as well as potentially
attacking on the f5 like Queen f3 what
are you gonna do there Queen f3 I was
gonna play Queen take C to pawn takes
you six and then take your bishop oh you
dirty dog your mating me I just showed
it on the analysis board for the fans at
home yeah okay so so let's not under
okay he doesn't go for this but
certainly the pressure on the fil is
more dangerous than I thought because I
admit I I missed this mate sack on f8
well this is really tough for black
because if you play Knight takes you six
the white knight goes to h5 and right f6
square backwards f7 pawn if you played
pawn takes g6 white can always play
moves at Queen f3 because if you could
probably Queen takes c2 y can play
Bishop takes H six months and the other
problem is even though the Kings on the
original square Robert let's not forget
it can't castle anymore right so white
could even play plants like h4 h5 try to
create new avenue avenues into the the
King side okay Queen to c1 is another
slow approach I was thinking of ways to
create more targets on the Kings side
and this does that there's also this f6
square begging for a piece to be put on
it you just you choose what you want to
put there and and whites pretty much
into it so okay this is this is not
ideal met now Bishop g5 is just on my
radar with ideas of taking you 7 and
then Queen G
five okay Bishop e6 perhaps even
stronger put the Queen on g5 behind it
this looks awful
you can put Bishop g7 even and put your
queen on h6 there it's just black can't
really move but I would take on g4 and
just hope and pray that I'm not getting
needed yeah if you take on g4 I guess
why can always trade on f8 a bunch of
times that put a queen h6 check and rook
to f1 and yoke and Dane here is
something like that doesn't seem good
for black but if my king can run to d7
then perhaps I get out of it and by
taking on g4 I playing King g7 maybe
back in the met you play tonight at five
and try to close down the position but
it looks awful the Queen's coming at g5
for white everything looks looks bad so
what is he thinking about here what is
he gonna do hey Dani is it too early to
resign it's never too early to resign in
a French I'm sure that belongs on a
t-shirt somewhere he's gonna trade bring
the Queen in and the rook comes to the F
file and as as my Canadian uncle once
said Bob's your uncle
so it's looks like it's pretty yeah
queen chief I've gained a temple on the
night there's threats of Knight h5
because the g6 pawn is pinned Nell good
stuff yep this is pretty straightforward
Knight h5 comes just can-can white right
I'm assuming black check King f7 has run
the Candace king of southern Queen f6
check wins you six that's really appeal
Knight h5 here just not h5 coming in to
f6 is a okay rook f1 also works
everybody cuz 95 you can even take twice
due to the fact that the G pawn is
pinned to the king yep here comes rook
up 6 I'm not sure I like the rook on f6
more than the night you know how I feel
about putting my ponies on outpost
squares well rook up 6 meter there's
Knight g8 rook f6 Knight g8 Queen h4
King g7 and you're living on a prayer
but you're still living so yes yeah
black is still surviving Queen h4 check
right away was also possible there
to bring the caught if I thought if
queen of for King g7 Queen f6 would pick
up the e6 pawn queen g8 this can't be
real there how is there not mate
somewhere on the H file please the chess
gods do justice to this position ok 9 H
5 by the way you can't take coz rook h6
has made everyone yep Knight h5 but
what's the what's the next move what's
the phret rook move away and then Knight
f6 ok but if you move the rook I can I
can almost take on h5 cuz there's no
work h6 mates so many sevens hanging and
if I take with a queen on e7 yeah ok
yeah yeah moving the Brookwood unleash
the Queen hitting the knight okay good
enough and good enough for both you and
I to feel right that despite Dany
wrenches rustiness not beating the
French this last weekend I think the the
rumors of the French demise are still
still accurate yeah this is I mean at
this level the I really do wonder why
these guys play the French Fabiano crush
the French himself at the US
Championship dominguez Perez has done
the same many times so I'm just you know
let's let's leave the French hatred to
to a later show but it definitely seems
like a suspect choice at this point
because LaVon was in charge of this game
from start to finish this move Queen h4
g5 okay but if we takes g4 is still just
about rook takes a fade oh wait it's
like I'm not winning material there no
no I think you just have to take g4
yeah I agree Fabiano should not still be
surviving this position at this point
but it's okay maybe maybe trade out if
they now Queen takes Queen takes g5 with
the threat of Knight f6 I don't I don't
see I don't see any yeah okay LaVon
LaVon agrees seems so maybe King h8 here
the idea being that now I can try to
trade Queens in the G file yeah that
waiting you're negative six check
doesn't come with the check so King in
shade if you had Knight of six like oh
wait oh I guess a it's the H six square
defend himself from ape and ninety-six
King h8 Queen g6 on the new Queen g7
that's Queen she's Queen g6 27 but Queen
h5 and then no you're right though it I
think LaVon must have missed some
opportunity earlier
when the rooks were still on the board
because you're already just less happy
that you haven't mated black yet here so
if you play Knight g4 and then you can
just trade off the Queen's at age six
and well let me think is this a winning
endgame it should be just your up and
h-bond so yeah where's your where's our
King and infiltrator yeah that's in it
okay we'd have to calculate but you'd
think there's a potential win but you're
right there's always danger of a
blockade when it's an edge pass pollen
so in King's you too good starting move
just you get to always take on each six
and you play king h3 here so if you're
trading on g4 then white just plays h4
h5 and then King h4 till you lose a
tempo that Burma came to g5 and that's
game over so you'll probably play h4 now
black is just kind of in six one here
okay a4 might also be a good idea to
consider because okay you have to worry
about the B sack and black gets his own
pollen here but you'll never have passed
pawn queen takes h6 take taking g4 h4 h5
comes out working five and then yeah
yeah
so the point everybody is White's gonna
rush the pawn up here eventually black
will be in opposition and have to back
up and white will infiltrate via g5 nf6
we'll see if Fabiana plays it out he
does not he throws in the towel and with
that we we check over to our our
scoreboard with all four cams in the
stats so to start out with LaVon being a
68% favorite according to our stats he
lost now now we're back in a situation
where with a win he sort of brought
things even and remains remains what
many would consider a favorite but we
are seeing the first signs of LaVon
LaVon fat heads I had to show some LaVon
support mostly fabbi fans in the chat
I'm not sure if that's surprising it
seems that way so far but LaVon strikes
back that'll teach you to stop playing
the French Robert I'm shocked you play
the French yeah you know that's what
happens when you hang out with Alejandra
Ramirez for a week yeah you start making
good pasta sauce and playing the front
yeah you know you may have some good
pasta sauce but you know you may make
some bad open
choices as well so all right now we're
in a dutch with black getting f5 early
really interesting structure here
actually
if black gonna play a four this early in
the game with the night on h5 for an
attack well I like blacks position
because now the bishop on g5 where's it
going isn't black and play f4 next tried
trapped the bishop yeah well hh6 and g5
are also possibilities if you can as
long as you're not worried about tactics
with the knight being loose on h5 which
maybe you should be but I'm not
so Knight b3 here it stops the Queen
taken on b2 and gives the bishop access
back to the D 2 square boom yeah I'm
still not liking when black plays f4 and
the fisherman g5 is just trap so as
LaVon leans off camera they're all I can
tell vice vice I forget his full
username saying he he's just concerning
to him that the players don't realize
how they look on camera well they're
kind of focused on playing chess and
they're not professional streamers
that's our job here so all I can say is
when me and Robin are on camera Robert
looks really good that's all I can say I
can't control if LaVon leans off camera
Wow I love you I love the one you lie to
me lie to me so night on h5 z g5 yep
let's analyze that of course white has a
lease of Perpetual there if not a mating
attack so be careful before playing a
move by g5 and if you don't play g5 you
can just bring your knight back to f6
but after Bishop takes f6 you'll have
some problems of interesting in the e5
square and your your backward pawn on
six one of the interesting things about
the bishop being here though Robert is
that it's okay now I was gonna say now
that the Knights defended the problem is
black isn't in a rush to get g5 black
black could prepare it as as LaVon is
attempting to do defending both east 6
NH 5 means that at some point you may
have a trap Bishop on h4 well I want you
to play g5 now because then I'll stick
with the bishop and then follow up with
taking with the night trying to hit your
Bishop on f7 and pawn on e6 so that's
the one thing that Fabiano has going
from in this immediate position that
said if black can take time so that how
do you may like work 88 here yeah
defend the e6 pawn so you can play g5
but anytime you play g5 I'll take with
the bishop right it's gotta be a build
up but at some point it's gonna be a
piece so right I like this move though
before because now that I can go from b3
to c5 uh-huh and target the bishop I can
even play pawn d5 myself just to kick
your night away from the protection the
e5 square and where's that night going
as the a5 square I guess but I think
work a e8 the Queen's seven Queen c7 um
maybe gonna forget about trapping the
bishop and prepare f4 with the battery
or he just wants the Queen to be able to
spy the Kings side as a defensive piece
in case he does decide to risk g5 well
he does protect the bishop with the
Queen which is really helpful because
now if you go she does a black is
another movie on his g5 yeah issue
thinks about HTML g5 the Queen protects
f7 which in turn protects h5 so you sort
of save that move and they also can go
always go back to g7 which is nice for
black because that defends six and make
sure your knight isn't hanging so yeah I
think black just is a good position yeah
and time is starting to suggest to us
that Fabiano agrees as he's leaning in
here and down almost a minute on the
clock maybe regretting his decision to
risk the bishop on h4
I'm not even sure that black isn't okay
I guess after if white played a move
like D 595 seems like a no-brainer you
unleash attacking chances to c3 and the
c-4 squares in out pull square but I'm
not even sure that it's that big of a
deal if this Knight went to a dark
square and let the bishop trade off just
because the bishop pair will be good for
black but I allow that if you're gonna
trap the bishop on h4 I guess yep and I
think from fabi's perspective he knows
he's gonna lose his piece no matter what
so he's trying to get a setup that's a
solid as possible so if he can take on
g5 mm-hmm take with the knight back on G
if I played f4 the question then becomes
how is black and a breakthrough is
that's a great point yeah alright
there's not much room to maneuver with
I'm looking at that right now to show
everybody you're lying it's a great
point that oh and it looks like that's
exactly what's happening in the game the
line we just showed so we'll find out if
LaVon thinks he can eventually maneuver
his way to using that extra piece ooh
c4 this is this is a long-term sacrifice
here for white this isn't something
where you sack a piece everyone cuz
Fabiano thinks he's gonna be mating the
king he's he's playing for long-term
compensation of of having a few clones
what he's getting it like rook c1 fall
by Knight c4 yeah rook see one night c4
this is uh maybe he's trying to show
Magnus that he's not the only one who
can Sacopee sack a queen for long-term
compensation
Fabiano trying to do the same thing yeah
that game with the David Nabarro was
awesome that was awesome and here
where's the Queen Gorgo to e7 I may
still just play Knight c4 because you're
in the ocean 1 d6 I want to take that
off the board
you're good knight on d4 we'll be
hanging if you move Bishop let's say and
you also you can't you can't advance any
more of these pawns here without without
more pieces becoming loose so yeah black
has--is work cut out for him I mean a
piece is a piece and in blitz you really
have to be accurate with compensation
because any any false step and your
initiative drizzles out then then black
will be up a minor but but I agree I
like white
I also okay so let's say Queen e7 is
played you can't play are you gonna play
nice c4 and trade d6 for g5 I guess so
right you wouldn't you would play nice
c4 right away and allow me to take g5
but maybe maybe that's not the right
idea maybe you need to protect h4 first
with some it is taken f7 actually I mean
you just get rid of that Bishop then
play Knight c4 if things seem to be
going White's way in a position like
that and it's very unclear my idea at
the end of lines like that is at some
point I'm gonna try to shoot a5 not to
just try to undermine the Queen side
pawns for white but try to open up the
rook on a8
okay well perhaps we're gonna get the
line you're discussing yep the knight
comes in to c4 and life force so I was
about to say should white have gone f4
before black played f4 because white
could have thrown in that movement and
said in 794 f4 for white you can't go
efore cuz your knight entity for would
have been hanging so maybe white miss an
opportunity to play f4 first that fors a
very nice move shutting down
White's huge counter playthrough with
attack on the e5 square yes so here yeah
you play pointy for you gotta get active
but okay so if black just sits on the
position it's it's okay what if I play
rook a to the 8th let's over protect the
bishop on d6 so the Queen is free
consider moves like King f8 at some
point to unpin the knight on g7 and and
start to unwind and use all of our
pieces where's your well I think White's
gonna trap in the white squares right
that's the one advantage that what has
the position but you eat for and then
try to maybe get something I'm happening
on the h7 Square ef6
I think I mean Black has to be
significantly better but if you play
move like f3 for black it's very
committal your pollen is maybe
overextended you're gonna have a hard
time keeping it and if you think about
the material as it is right now black
has a piece a knight for two pawns so
that's actually quite a deal of
compensation so anytime if white looks
to get that third pawn that would be
tremendous conversation if not a better
position so you have to be very careful
in positions like this with black yeah
but again all that said I don't know I
mean I get skeptical of whether white
can keep the initiative in these types
of positions as time pressure becomes
mutual I think it's easier sometimes to
play with the extra piece but we'll see
if white can create threats on the light
squares before both sides are under 30
seconds here both sides nearly under a
minute
I like Queen of 6 again if I'm playing
black here I want to play King f8 I
still want to try to get my Knight to f5
and I expect LeBlanc to play him of like
King f8 or King h8 at some point try to
try to start using his extra piece
instead of just looking at it
yakov and in the in the game chat saying
is this a special match of some kind
apparently he's in his own universe
classic yaakov but shout out to
everybody in the chat we see all of our
all of our twitch regulars being
welcoming welcome everybody
we got Tommy we got chess bay we've got
bjh Timothy Connelly herbs V sim thanks
everybody who's here
he was if not I got next as if he's
automatic replacement even if they
weren't playing match Jakub not only
living in his own world but presuming
LaVon and Fabiano would love to dive
into a match with him I guess Brooksie
to d1 I'm not sure about that move
because you need your hook on the Open
File taking on d6 and putting a rip to
c8 for example yeah and to give some
chances now black is consolidating what
can't wait even do here yeah I'm
starting to like black more and more
just because despite the the pressure
the white has in terms of compensation
like I said I feel like there's a lack
of concrete ways that white keeps the
initiative Queen h5 I like everything
Greentree g4 back that thing up now
maybe Fabi plays f3 to support and
eventually tries to use a couple of
passers look out right here rook h3 nice
maybe no I think f3 makes more sense
anyway because we want to get it we want
to get these pawns as long-term chances
for for playing against the night but
I'm gonna lose that rather lose quickly
and at least threaten something oh so
we're down to 15 17 second range got a
deal with the threat on c4 Knight a5
rook f7 LaVon speeding up here comes h4
just go 98 okay we're not about the
night we just come back to you and g7
scores really bad for this piece so oh
there it goes now g5 because there's no
Knight coming into h5 but LaVon says
I'll fix that comes right back to g7
brings the knight back into the nice
square here comes the knight to g3 or e3
well were caged 7 would have won the h1
running the spot actually aa rock h7 was
even stronger there everybody back up
the analysis board to show you what's
going on now white dress for a pawn look
at that so LaVon may LaVon may be
regretting he missed rook h7 the d6 pawn
starting to run only a few seconds on
the clock rook to u1 coat oh yes later
for he's threatening baby how sweet okay
but it's still not enough all he's doing
is winning back material still down the
exchange
yep but he's down the exchange but how
many pawns does he have and is he's got
can I bury flu almost no time on the
clock here takes me for it Big Z for
Brooke take c4 here comes the F pond
okay well LaVon 96 no new Bishop f1 it's
winning forgot to be enough now he gives
up okay he wins the bishop on c4 should
be near should be enough that was no he
didn't have 96 I'm freaking out because
I'm thinking I'm seeing blunders that
I'm not and both these players we don't
know how quite good they are in bullets
right well the Fabi held his own against
Hikaru last year and this is should be
easy win especially with one second
increment here right but time travel
gets you time trouble will get you if
Gloria Stephon warned us the rhythm is
going to get you the okay b6 but still
there's just not enough black will
gobble one point at a time interesting
decision there I think it's just gonna
take c6 and Ewing nice technique
actually nice technique there by LaVon
winning the first player to win with the
black pieces it is Aronian and so far
he's he's living up to our to our
predictive odds Robert as far as what we
expect to happen in the in the match
based on the fact that a lot of what our
data said is that LaVon is a slightly
better bullet player so to answer that
question when when the gloves come off
and time scrambles but okay we'll see so
far it's a 2-1 lead we have our first
one with the black pieces and Aronian
jumps out to a lead that was crazy
because now we're in a classical
slow-moving Italian game shout out to
Bobby who has played for Italy in the
past so he should be able to handle this
position but that was just nuts that
yeah and ending the seem like I don't
have an engine in front of me but seemed
like things were swinging back and forth
yeah where LaVon was just so far ahead
and all of a sudden Fahd was back in it
by taking the b7 pawn but then the e4
pawn break seal the deal and that was
that was awesome well I mean and again I
think in these rapid time controls
sometimes it's harder to prove the
type of compensation that in an over the
board tournament I think the evaluation
that white had enough of a bind to
justify the piece was probably right but
I think it's difficult and blitz without
a concrete plan eventually the piece
kind of proves itself yep and let's see
right now speaking of plans
well coming up with a plan for black
isn't always easy here white is
pressurizing the h6 square for black you
can't you don't really have any central
pawn breaks because white is so well
defending the Center for example
sometimes is black you take on d4 I play
moves like C five votes officialnaye
seven let's do any sense if you take on
d4 play for d5 is black and white will
just push the pawn to e5 give me more
space because the bishop let's see two
is strong so playing c5 immediately is
an option but you have to as I was gonna
say it to be careful about the h6 policy
defense the h6 pawn if I'm black oh I'm
white here I play book A to D one yeah
just build up its continue building the
Senate or Jeb blender my a to pawn
sometimes I forget that a to pawns are
hanging you and Bobby Fischer so you're
in good company although that was h2 but
shout out to our last sub thanks for
being here
death by y and ur one one one six said
he wants LaVon to win and carry his
bracket I wonder how far he took Aronian
in the in the bracket contest I I wonder
how far we're gonna we're gonna be
diving into to fab ease afro if he keeps
leaning in like that we get a pretty
good glimpse of his of his fro he's
letting his soul glow it looks great
from that angle
ya know he's clearly using a good like
dandruff free shampoo you know no you
need a hair product endorsement yeah be
good he's got a lot of people with him
right now for anybody who follows
Fabiano on social media you know that
Fabiana was preparing hard for the World
Championship he's got a chef with him
he's got a physical trainer he's got
some chest trainers hey that's what
they're doing I feel they were preparing
for this match for the last two weeks
oh yeah no it's sorry yeah I know the
speech chess match definitely higher on
fabi's priority list than a world
championship match so all right here
comes h4
white is sort of just gonna poke and
prod here and black kind of has a
perspective in this structure sort of
come and get me big boy because black is
very solid not really any weaknesses
long term and if white overextends
that's what that's what black wants is
targets whether it's the pawns
overextend on the Kings side or here
here he'll probably take take on b3 and
then play Bishop e6 and try to use the a
file maybe yeah taking on b3 playing
Bishop e6 try to trade rooks I'm all I'm
concerned about dragging the Queen away
for the Queen side that's Lee's plays
Bishop e6 first maybe that's the smarter
idea as you said so now now you're
actually threatening to take and take a1
without having to worry about your queen
leaving the center as you said let's see
do i attack your b5 pawn hmm okay d1
just ignoring saying that people have
rook a to I guess white we'll just like
keeper k1 network it went back hangs III
play soon and c1 queen a8 building up on
the a file right I definitely like
blacks was more than I did several moons
ago work a to d1 in that position looks
strange handing over the a file this is
the type of counter plate of black
needed yeah cuz now now if you played
Bishop d1 I follow your Bishop to the
first rank of played rook a one was
looking good yeah and there's not really
any justification for moves like g4 h5
here if your queen is gonna be
distracted on the Queen side you're
probably not gonna get any kind of
meaningful attack I still wonder about
g4 and g5 for white if you can make the
dark square breakthrough work you have
some you have some pawns on age six and
f6 to to try to pry open okay but no
he's kind of abandoning this idea
probably will just settle on closing up
the King side and maybe g4 now to g4 or
Knight f3 to h4 or two moves I consider
I like black you would like black here
sorry I don't know where that came from
that's totally uncalled for buddy I just
don't see what White's doing here
they just seems like white has become a
little bit aimless now queen a3 for
black just keep making progress
yeah b3 is a problem and you don't want
to have to play d5 here and just
relinquish all your center Center
pressure Bishop c4 that's interesting
Fabiano's going after the d4 pawn by
pinning and undermining the protection
on f3 so can black continue right right
so if I take on f3 White's trying to
claim that the two bishops are good so
nicely six played to try to hit the d4
pawn b4 is now a threat I'm pretty big
threat actually for blacks maybe white
should play B for himself something to
think about I like before
b4 for black if that happens problems on
these pawns okay Bishop d3 trying to be
b4 tactically with Bishop b5 yeah
pinning the knight on c6 so so fabi's
got some things to think about before he
just rushes before ahead but the tactics
are starting to get nuts here right I
mean you're almost in a position where
you could consider taking on d2 and
playing b4 anyway just undermining the
whole center structure the problem is if
you take 1 d2 it's a good my knight so
you can never take on a3 but it but if
you take with the night then
then d4 is weaker so now before there's
there's all kinds of tactics where you
might even sack the exchange to win the
D pawn yeah but now I thought that white
could play d5 with the C file being
broken open the c7 square becomes very
vulnerable so I think I'm looking at b4
here and what would you play after
Knight takes b4 now before I play d5
okay I thought I could take on c3 with
tempo on the night and and that was a
profitable way for me to bring this
night in to d4 but okay he doesn't go
for this instead he just take straight
up he's gonna trade the D pawn for the
b-pawn and the end of the line white
takes on b5 wait is there an e5
discovered shut you know how I feel
about checks come on get excited people
i mean ii 5 check i guess you can just
move your king back and say what
what's your next move but it looks scary
you know with all these vulnerable light
squares you need a night to go to h4
square to deliver the goods but now
that's an interesting move I think he's
kind of saying if you if you over
protect that I was c5 now I'll take and
have this e five check to take d6 no
because the Brooke would be pinned on e1
at the end so you place c5 and I
probably go be forwards should I get the
b5 on well I guess if c5 I can play e5
check right away before taking d4 and
then take d6 in fact I know he doesn't
go he does what you said he just takes
d4 takes b5 no more no more discovered
checks on the docket so if you go rook
two options rook c8 or a v8 I'm I'm
sorry I wanted rookie five but hey I'm a
greedy man yes or Sarah want chess okay
rook e7 but I do think keeping the rook
on the e-file as is useful now move the
King back avoid discovered checks I
assume I assume as they say
now black can play d5 and try to trade
off one of these ugly double pawns but
now Bishop c5 to meet before with rook
visa okay
shout out to play the Grob chess bay and
everybody spam and the uncle Sasha emote
I don't know that uncle Sasha is gonna
be here today you know he usually lets
me handle the speech as championships
professionally on my own so well who
knows your father's just blunder what he
blood her well he bunted his pawn to d6
after 94 he can just run Bishop to c5
and said he gave away this pawn I don't
think that was intentional haha
yeah looking at the analysis board after
94 I don't see any reason why Bishop c5
although b4 would have been played on
that he's good month he could meet with
a piece in the B file just paying that
be pawn so I thought roughly 7 within
the response now he look it was just
down upon and the night went from c4
over to f5 and look at LaVon breaking
over the position here yeah and plus
time is is favoring LaVon again and oh
this move Knight h4 that's a problem
that's a big problem it's slick it's
it's also overworked in aids used by b5
b6 and just pushed that pawn yeah we got
problems here if you're black that light
squares are 99 of them and there's even
ideas where you might bring the Bishop
to c4 I was just gonna say and then at
some point you're eyeing ideas of light
square she's over here in 96 I like that
Queen takes your threatening Queen f7
and that was kind of the battery I was
going for with Bishop c4 yeah I'm liking
white this would be a huge game LaVon
jumping out to a two-game lead would be
an early tone setter for the match Queen
f7 it'sa Bishop d3 just made showing the
other white squares
Queen f7 don't I meet you on g8 anyway
Queen f7 then I move my Bishop Bishop
takes before but yeah this is you have
to sacrifice the exchange yeah also good
enough okay well I mean this is a a big
a big comeback at this point gotta be
right considered a big comeback well yes
dropping the first game and now winning
three straight it's not not every day
that a player five and a car Juana's
caliber Queen side castles to remind
everybody if you're just joining us as
we're viewers are increasing just a
reminder that this is the speed chess
championship 2018 Levon Aronian now out
to a two-game lead against world
championship challenger Fabiano Caruana
and the American has his work cut out
for him I think Levon is he came to play
right that Oh to record in the sec
lifetime I think he's tired of not
having a win on the board so and we see
all four games have been decisive and I
got to give a shout out to our stats guy
chest kid mr. Macklin he says that all
four games have been decisive and in
their last 11 rapid and blitz games 10
of those 11 have been decisive over the
board these guys these guys play chess
to win it you know they don't make
drawers they don't make drawers
diagonal lady says LaVon in the mood
wonder what he's listening to well he
took off his headphones now and he's
he's focused I'm sure he'll put him back
on in a moment we'll ask them along with
his feelings about the Celtics chances
now that Toronto has acquired the
services of Kawhi Leonard but their
head-to-head matchup over the board also
courtesy of my client is seven to six in
favor of Fabiano for those of you who
keep track of that sort of stuff so
these guys that that's only a one game
difference either way right Robert so
this is kind of that's why a lot of us
felt this was a coin-flip match coming
in even with levanto two games right now
absolutely and I glad that LaVon turn
his Bill Simmons podcast off and is
continuing to focus on the chess here
yeah I wonder if he's a New England fan
in general like of all their sports I
would guess not I think a lot of people
become Celtics fans who live outside of
Boston but partly because they're
they're such a nationally and
internationally covered team the Celtic
pride all right so what do we got here
what do we got here I'm wondering what
this nice doing on g5 I guess it can
come to e4 but I love black setup it's
very flexible you have everything well
defended the e5 pawn is covered you have
upon 85 which stops white from playing
b4 yep now Ben and d3 is really the only
positional weakness on the board which
just means that white is trying to
defend that pawn either as you said by
bringing the Knight to e4 which blocks
the bishop or at some point maybe you
try to strike with d4 if you can get
away with it tactically but I tend to
look at a lot of these open center
Italian structures and and feel like if
white didn't doesn't get an initiative
quickly that the long-term positional
compensation is in blacks favor because
of this D pawn right that backwards pawn
is give me a nuisance to deal with I was
thinking that Bishop b3 was gonna be
played okay if rook 88 happens Bishop e3
might be play and the points if they're
fish of g6 I can try to play for h4 and
started kicking this bishop on the Kings
side maybe it didn't work out Tommy
coming through with his sub and says he
has a positional weakness for Danny
wrenches body must have been a typo but
shout out to all 4,500 of you with us
right now a jump in viewership so for
though
of you just joining the speeches
championship for the first time this is
the biggest event in online chess in the
online chess world don't go anywhere the
world champion Fabiano Caruana taking on
Armenia's number one chess superstar and
chess gangster self self-described chess
gangster Levon Aronian yeah love is a
quite an interesting guy here and he's
playing extremely well in the first four
games up three two one yell in this
match and here with the black pieces h4
finally does happen so black has to make
an important structural decision do you
play HC yeah keep your bishop on this
diagonal which weakened some of your
light squares if those bishops get
traded or play move like Queen f7 which
ties your pieces down to each other
because with the Queen on f7 you're
saying I need to keep an eye on the age
five squares Bishop f5 the survival is
the the other option but the main reason
why we like Bishop a5 everyone is it
kind of prevents h5 because of their the
four kanji for if it wasn't for that
fork I think white plays h5 anyway
because there's a threat of h6 to
undermine all of blacks pawns but but
okay Fabiano sees Bishop c4 slides the
Queen over to g3 Robert
but here comes h5 and H for I feel like
this is this has become the kind of
position we said that white needed to
get an initiative on the Kings side in
order to compensate for this week
backward pawn on d3 and it feels like
white is starting to get some pressure
here comes my that way yeah Bishop on c1
people may be wondering well that's a
move and a weak piece you know what I'm
looking at now call me crazy but don't
call me Shirley can I take on h6 and
play Knight takes f6 well I'll take on
e4 if you take on aged six so you you've
always been an intermezzo son of a gun
should take c4 yes d4 look at that
before open opens up the bishop on c2
yeah it also opens up the attack on the
c7 squares if you take with the pawn on
d4 I can play Knight take C seven and
yeah you're coming traps so it this is
the idea everybody that the Roberts
pointing out look at that battery very
nice night II d5 or something like that
I just want to get my pieces out and the
problems with these positions for black
is your pieces are sort of stepping on
each other the 90s seven it prevents the
Bishop from and that faith from getting
active you know I don't know if I like
that decision well I think I think he
tactically was was struggling
with with frets that the knight on e4
had there were threats of knights e5
Robert droughts on f6 so despite that
light squares maybe he feels like he he
he can tactically justify this move
because after the knight moves is he
just winning the d4 plug with the with
the Queen and rook battery on d4 but I'm
happy to give him a pawn in exchange for
the light score domination right but I
also thought rookie 4 is better than
Bishop e4 because the work on e4 pretend
protected that very d4 square so
interesting them perhaps was an
opportunity there for to guard d4 by
Fabiano and maybe even swing the rook
over here that's the net that's the line
Robert was talking about alright we're
gonna find out if Levon can justify the
week light squares for the D pawn that
he is now winning and so we'll see who
evaluated it correctly yeah I just take
on d4 back now is you take and I take
with the Queen right then maybe you have
Bishop e3 yep okay but I have a even
have Queen before if not taking on e4
well taken before losses in exchange at
the very least shout-out to candy codes
who just resubmit GV chess channel thank
you for your support
apparently he likes using himself some
double blunder emotes so appreciate that
he or she I don't know man
I'm a pawn grabber by nature you know
that I although actually okay the more I
look at where I wonder if I should play
Knight B to D 5 and play positionally
making making use of the fact that this
is a long term weakness the fact that
it's isolated because Queen takes d4
yeah it's gonna get very very risky
Levon down emitted on time now certainly
has a lot to think about here before
gobbling on d4 yeah so I'd like your I
didn't I be d5 you're still playing in
the old romantic style of well I see an
isolated pawn I'm just gonna block hate
it and I'll go with it later yeah and
that's the thing if you take that
isolated pawn now Weiss pieces move a
little more freely like we said Bishop
so what happens on Bishop III what if I
just take you for you take message right
but I move the Queen I'm sacking the
exchange happily given that I have a
couple pause and you've just lost your
light squared Bishop I mean I'm looking
at the position on the analysis board
thinking that this might be the best way
to eliminate White's attacking chances
okay the extra Brooks are really nice
and maybe white just plays rookie in
rookie one at the end of a line like
that and grabs the center but hi I think
I think LaVon might risk risk it to get
the biscuit in regards to simplifying
this position yeah III you could even
play your move Queen before as you
mentioned earlier that way if Knight
comes to c2 in hitting them oh that's a
nice idea yeah this little this little
maneuvering Intermezzo of everyone by
Robert means that if you try to
overwhelm by Queen now when I take and
you take I get an extra piece on c2 so
that's um more more evidence that
perhaps LaVon can get away with this
whole idea I would probably try to play
b3 here because of course you can take
on b3 I'll put overcome b1 and if you do
you move your knife from b6 I'll
eventually put my Knight to c4 so I like
protecting that c4 square and the a4
bond as well so yell Queen f3 played
okay so I'm wondering if black and just
play f5 here saying if you take on that
five I'll give you the pawn back and now
now Knights coming to d4 this is what I
didn't want to see from levonne's point
of view is that this light-square
control is worth the pawns right the
king is very unsafe in the h8 square
because if that cui can get in front of
the bishop there will be mating ideas so
yep okay Bishop d2 I don't know about
cuz now f5 again I would just play at
five and if you take me well I'm trading
off your light square bishop and that's
the only thing that's making me feel
incredible yeah cuz we don't like the
long-term potential and some of the
reason why Robert evaluates that
everybody is because even if you don't
see a mate when you know you have
permanent weaknesses in a sort of
structure meaning these pawns can never
go back to protect the King you always
have to think about how do I eliminate
my opponent's dominance of those squares
before they become a tactical problem
later on so okay I agreed with you that
maybe if I was right and we'll see if
LaVon regrets it Robert is now under 30
seconds if he if he ends up losing
because of potential tactics on the
light squares he may he may wish he had
that back yep and now his Queen us go c5
so you could throw in Bishop e3 you can
just take on before and the 97 is doing
very well to defend this Kings do you
keep it there it
I'm trying to figure out how to write I
know if I'm white I wish I could just
take my rook on e 1 and eliminate the
night on e 7 to do anything I could to
open up access to these squares yeah
it's it's a bit of a nuisance so unhappy
he's not playing bug house we'd be we'd
be asking for knights and pawns on the
light squares and black would be mated
sufficiently three Queen see for now
Knight can go to a3 back if we don't
want to Trey the Knights Inn that gains
a tempo he took them before mean takes
where is oh wait is there Bishop takes
h6 lurking he doesn't go for it I'm
wondering if there was an opportunity to
take aged six with this Queen takes f6
but maybe f5 would have been played
anyway f5 is so well timed because yeah
five you commissioned c2 now Queen takes
b2 that's a hanging pawn can you take it
maybe what'll Queen g4 yeah ah get the
Queen's off the board okay white husband
should be six in the end though yeah
Fabiano finds 85-95 that way you trade
the rooks off and detective bish
wouldn't be six o95 here is a nice move
oh I know buddy okay he maybe could have
traded and played Bishop a5 anyway okay
but I hear ya 95 was nice this is a
risky move because now the knight is
pinned and there's threats of Bishop g6
in a lot of positions everybody
yeah both both of them are playing under
the duress of time I don't know but
something something about this is help
is I'm smelling blood for white here
look at the time look at the fact that
the LightSquared bishop is still on the
board i feel like black is is one move
away from just blundering this game away
under time pressure I agree just rook F
1 here for white yep okay Brooke F 1
would have been nice you don't want to
play rook up to here I don't think yeah
he trades maybe a 5 now for white keep
the pawn make the b7 pawn backward yep
Fabiano goes for it king h2 and then any
works ending is just lost for black as
bishop c8 comes to win that b7 pawn so
if i would think about gonna work a
three here that way bishop takes B -
I've rook b3 so I like getting my Brook
in front of the pawns I would just keep
the bishops on the board yeah he plays
Bishop e1 I agree now maybe even g4 I
think you can do it
save the bishop or a treasure before to
f3 very safe score and played b4 b5 nice
nice fine b4 b5 everybody by Robert uses
the bishop to undermine these pawns on
the light squares
eventually get the a pond that was my
bosses of the trick ba because I think
he should have gone for your idea though
this Bishop is super well-placed to
undermine blacks pawns everybody well so
blacks getting some counter plating yeah
I see three back time pressure trying
pressure both sides nothing nothing
couldn't eat more I think he finds a six
I didn't like a six there but make it so
winning the rook is overloaded now with
the trade favors black rook to D 2 or B
2 or B 8 is it I don't know this rook
and my name's gonna be winning I don't I
know I don't think it is this looks like
you know g5 is good she's live in King
g4 very nice h6 in King age no Ice Age 6
KH army with g4 is black I think even
here even here he's gonna sacrifice the
eight-ball to draw and then he pushes
pawn down the board you can't protect
age 6 yep a 2 a 2 G for it's not in time
Queen my flag though he's close Maggie's
down to just a couple seconds Fabiano's
not just gonna give him a draw here oh
he is okay there you go wow wow wow wow
wow it feels like Fabiano let one slip
slightly right given the fact that he
had a lot of pressure there with both
players under time pressure the bishop
pair your plan on the light squares was
strong right that just that was shocking
return of events that both both the
players that had just looked at them on
camera they were clearly feeling the
pressure of them looking because LaVon
sort of breathe a sigh of relief after
was done they haven't rematched yet so
I'm analyzing this game here
highlighting Roberts plan back in the
position with the bishop on f3 I think
that recognizing where your opponent's
weaknesses are in that endgame driving
the b-pawn and creating a passer on the
light squares was was probably the most
accurate approach there from Fabiano
everybody did my best to show it to you
before this next game got aborted who
knows why but because I've got another
white we're supposed to be black now AHA
they are boarding the game and we will
restart in just a moment so interesting
stuff here so far if we take a look at
at our stats remember everybody that to
start
this match based on the history of these
players not only on our site but also
just sort of an algorithm that puts
together their performances through the
history of the speeches championship
specifically in this format a lot a lot
of people had Levon Aronian as a slight
favor you can see starting there with
his yellow bar he was nearly a 70%
favorite and part of that is because
according to how we see these guys
perform under time pressure Levon tends
to be slightly better in time scrambles
and in the bullet portion based on these
these guys results so I'm with Robert
I feel like this matches a little more
of a coin flip than the stats would
suggest but right now Levon holds a
two-game lead and Robert give us your
give me your 30-second summary on what
you've seen so far in this match as far
as the overall reason why Levon is up
two games
well lavon's been getting great
positions of the opening Fabiano played
the French defense in one game and I say
that with kind of a thing it wasn't hard
to get that out that he played the
French defense in one game yeah you play
the French and he got absolutely
pummeled in that one and then with the
black pieces in that game where we saw a
Levon go up the a minor piece and win
the game Levon wasn't very solid he's
been playing aggressively but not over
ambitiously right so he's taking chances
when they come to him rather than just
forcing the issue now Fabiano I didn't
like his choice in this particular game
because the very solid setup here in the
Sicilian and one nice thing that Bob
Brown was doing that we haven't seen to
some other matches just playing a
different opening pretty much every game
yo so he played with I'd have maybe one
reason why he played the French but
that's an opening I doubt he'll revisit
right but he is dabbling across the
board and Jeb we've seen that makes it
hard for Levon to just pinpoint his
weakness because it's kind of like
shooting a target that's moving all over
the place right but highlighting the
fact that Levon is up a couple games at
this point as we move back to the
analysis board I mean is that is that
strategy maybe not working or you feel
like this is an investment in the long
term you think that Fabiano is sort of
probing right now trying to find
something he likes so that as the time
controls get faster he's got an opening
that he's prepared to play against Levon
and bullet how much you think match
strategy is playing into the the fact
that he's bouncing around a lot in the
first stage yeah I definitely see your
point I just think that some of these
games have come down to time trouble
like that last game Fabiana should have
I'm for sure he outplayed him through a
large portion of the game LaVon was
playing resourceful E but he also got
himself it's a huge time trouble and I
don't know I think that Fabia should not
be counting himself out at all okay that
the two-game lead for LaVon is not
insurmountable by any means and I do
question both players bullish skills I
have no idea who is the superior bullet
player and in this particular game that
we have on the board right now I like
blacks position you have firm control
over many of the games vital squares
there's no kingside pawn break for white
which means that blacks are playing on
the queenside I think usually has to use
the C foil particularly because this is
a backward pawn we see a great Sicilian
for black there are no Knights coming to
the d5 square because they're all the
Knights are traded if you're ever okay
g4 is one of those over-ambitious things
now you just put over cause c8 either
one and go for the C pawn if you go rook
F to I go Bishop h4 and you can't
protect your C pawn anymore so in fact I
think black just winning the soupçon by
brute force take on c2 now or play f6
first I got started at six well like I
don't expect to see a French I'm gonna
make a prediction that I don't know if
Fabiano plays the Sicilian again that
Levon goes back to this G 3 system he
chose here I'm not sure that he feels
that way yet but it feels like black
equalized very early with this expansion
on the Queen side and Fabiano playing
very quickly almost a minute up on the
clock here shows he kind of knows this
Sicilian that we're showing on the
analysis board perhaps a little bit
better than LaVon being that he's up on
the clock and as you said the c2 pawn is
a problem how you gonna defend it he
definitely knows the sunbed move on
because lavon's not an e4 player and
that doesn't mean he hasn't studied
these games but probably an intensive
experience playing this so in his flat
and he's an e4 player is white so he
gets these positions from the white side
as well yeah one of the one of the few
players with the guts to take on someone
like MDL in the knight orifice Fabiano
who's uh who's shown willingness to do
that both in classical and when he
played Maxime in the speeches
championship last year
yep so right now I think that this is
five game of five I don't really has to
yeah I agree this is a game that with a
minute up on the clock here c2 hanging
d5 being
in the air which is a very common break
everybody in the Sicilian if black can
break on d5 and you know bring even more
pieces out in the center white is you've
really in trouble but okay LaVon plays
Rica three he's all-in right now on the
attack right he's trying to say I'm
gonna defend the c2 pawn by not by
defending it but by attacking sherbert
is rook g8 so I'm just defending my G
file this may be the reason why I've
worked B to c8 could have been his rook
on C it was such a good move because the
rook can swing back to the King side for
black without wasting time as pawn on c3
so now black do I play d5 to get my
darts for Bishop out or do I just take
on g3 they're up the Queen d7 could take
on g3 and now Queen waiting for Queen d7
to come because Queen d7 allows blocks
by d5 you have to undermine the defense
of the f5 ponent also threatens the pawn
it for Queen d7 here is great yeah I
agree I just highlighted I think that's
a great move Queen d7 there will be a
break on d5 f5 will fall and there will
be subs being gifted here shout-out to
distant fire who just gifted Jaron is
carrying a sub to the chess channel here
appreciate all three that you've gifted
here more than 6000 6500 of you with us
don't go anywhere the actions just
beginning we only have 20 minutes left
in the five-minute portion before we
move on to three-minute chess and before
Robert starts to to get crazy that's
what happens in three minute Robert gets
wild a little bit I can't control myself
here but right now I'm really digging
Bobby's position yes Jack is back rank
issues and those King of stuck on h8 but
the tactics are very much working in
this favorite and a black of another
move well I can't say about g4 but I can
play move like Queen to e8 trying to
snake my queen over the h5s well if you
look at the white king it's not actually
that's safe there might be some problems
in the dark squares as well as I love
that point I just highlighted that with
these dark squares being a problem maybe
there's a mating net in White's future y
can put the Queen on h5 and bring the
bishop out
look look for that King on h2 to not be
as safe as he looked like he is right
now yeah I'll get the clock story I
agree no it's this is uh as you said
LaVon not an e4 player by trade and
certainly doesn't get a lot of Sicilians
maybe
maybe this is the last time we see him
dive into this stuff Danny what kind of
life do you think LaVon ass I'm very
curious I can't help but stare and it's
a disco strobe light one fun fact about
Levon Aronian just in his free time he
practices his dance moves all day that's
all he does
so maybe he's into those you've heard
about those like silent raves now where
everybody has headphones on yeah maybe
he's into silent raves F through his
plays it is black oh queen c8 here or
Bishop d6 Queen c8 I think I'd go just
to get out of the pan bishop
whoa D for undermining he's not not
gonna continue the pressure here what
does he see about the e4 pawn that he
likes here maybe Bishop c6 and queen b7
I think I'll start either with well you
get a rook c2 c3 Ahmad if I'm getting
mated you know by the g5 quite yet so
alright plays Queen there now I don't
want to go Queen c2 me though although
if your Queen c2 Reagan if you trade on
c3 to go to the B pond and that would be
a very favorable exchange black but
white you go Queen G to probably just
swing the Queen over to the kids that's
important to note the bishop on h6 does
protective rook on c1 yeah it's
important to note that everybody in New
York has a car alarm - so we appreciate
that the I'm a little surprised by d4 by
Fabiana Robert honestly I feel like
maybe maybe that wasn't necessary yet to
ease the tension there okay so the
Vaughn wants to play moves like rook D -
bishop d1 to overprotect C - then play
rook d3 and kick the Queen out
okay so Bishop basic stops that I just
want black - like Bishop f8 at some
point and try to trade off these the
bishop it's really annoying me that I
can't maneuver my King at all and so now
Bishop c5 Oh see if I'm also an option
one of those moves Bishop c5 threatens
d3 but he decides that he likes your
plane of relieving the dark squares
so let's see Queen h4 going for the f6
bond yep there it's played shout out -
yes pay for the sub - nerve huh ChaCha
appreciate it so what can I do here I
can take on h6 no I don't I don't know
if I like that Bishop h6 Queen six rook
g7 that way you don't take on f6 go
check your work on d2 is hanging your
official enough three is hanging so
maybe they're tactically I can get away
with that yeah at one point at the end
of that line is if white plays a move
like rook up - then black is eventually
shooting d3 which is gonna undermine
both the B and the a pawn to win on the
Queen side yeah Queen e3 is a great
Queen trade for blacks as well so you
have to be careful about that yo so
Bishop h6 Queen six work G seven how
does white continue there a lot of paint
pieces I don't know how Jess bay
continues to gifts up she's up to 70
gifted subs on our channel thank you for
that last one - hallelujah cat thank you
to everybody that's here we almost
crossed 7000 viewers we appreciate all
of you sticking around right now because
it's only gonna get more exciting
Fabiano needs to win this game he's been
better from the start Livan doesn't
really have any business playing in the
Sicilian with Viviano at this level so
black is better but but now both sides
are under a minute Robert and Fabiano
still hasn't proven anything yet on the
Queen side but here comes d3 maybe d3 b3
is gonna be undermined and I'm I'm
nervous about White's position well I'm
nervous I'll playing d3 because Queen a7
looks that's a shot that is a shot right
there
out of nowhere yes Queen eight seven
hang the bishop on a system maybe even
get away with it
that's how blunders are made right there
wait can I eat em I don't like Queen B -
just so I can go after the C pawn but
you probably nuff to back and then
what's my queen doing on the beets who's
where Wow Thank You Tommy
thank you all of our subs Queen B -
Bishop d1 okay but now White has
actually coordinated a shot of g5 coming
in don't don't fall asleep on on the
Jeep on braking and all of a sudden this
King is under fire well Queen c3 either
now if you play g5 maybe I can play
Queen C there is a reaction
so they actually Oh Queen C Wow Queen c1
the rook is pin to the bishop on h6
Bax the queen up to g2e now bishop f8
okay we should be seven threatens to
take e4 cuz this coin is a clock
situation loaded ten seconds LaVon has
to play Bishop of three I don't know
okay I don't know why he took so much
time that I think that was the only move
now perhaps rookie Oh rookie to would
have allowed Queen h4 so Brooke c3 here
yeah okay it looks like Fabiano is gonna
convert take take Queens III takes takes
Queen to c3 go after the B and the a
pawn and just win yourself an endgame
whoa well I'll be oh no once more oak
we'd be what was a blunder
wait Queens coming out over to the to be
5 into e8 and me you can't stop me oh my
gosh what a turnaround I mean doesn't
matter he brings the Queen back Queen up
- Queen up to now Queen of 2 wrong
Square Queen d5 thread and meet on the
spot now play I think maybe if I began
his winning he still gets the win oh my
gosh what a turnaround and LaVon leans
in and brushes his shoulder off
literally that was a shoulder brush-off
right there did you see that I did see
that i mean i think he did i think LaVon
knows what he was doing I think he he
just went lemon brushed his shoulder off
after making a huge comeback to take a
three-game lead against the American Wow
what did Fabiano do wrong I mean he was
crushing the whole time pressure on the
Queen side yet didn't convert eventually
mutual time pressure got him which again
a lot of what I look at this matches
what will be the separator of LaVon wins
which is time scrambles and bullet and
so we'll see if Fabiana can prove us
wrong
thank you liquid product appreciate the
the bits and the mind-blowing miss yeah
that was amazing an amazing finish that
was unbelievable and I think that we've
seen this from Fabi in over the board
chest plenty of times in the grant chest
or he gets low on the clock he makes
blunders and you know he had a great
position there and Aronian the preview
said that he was worried about being
flagged but now he's won two games on
time so yeah one thing I don't know that
we've talked a lot about Robert and only
because it's it's not it's more abstract
than of course the the X's and O's going
on but let's remember that this year's
SCC has
only a one-second increment last year
both the five-minute and the
three-minute portions were a two-second
increment this time those time scrambles
maybe won't allow for quite the same
quality chess when here when you're down
on the clock right I mean right now
given that we've seen a couple of games
that were lost either on time or because
of time I think that's an interesting
thing to know for sure that that
difference is actually monumental people
may not realize that the difference in
two second one second increment is
hugest yeah and okay so now way and I'm
happy okay I like what Fabi did here he
played the same opening in London he
repeated the initial moves but he found
an improvement because all of a sudden
black is looking a bit vulnerable on
some of these squares like the sixth
ranked pawns g 6f 6 e six they stopped
White's pieces from pushing forward by
the same time they could be come victim
to a swift attack something like h4 h5
yet not another question I mean it is
with an IMG 7 but and then I move to fi
for example and these six okay like how
lavon's handling this is well looks it's
just sitting tight I guess yeah looks
like what has this spatial avenge you
could take out c4 at some point and try
to put a knight on d5 so it might good
right now playing and also obviously the
risk though is that each six becomes a
target but I guess what you're saying is
with the knight on d5 there's not really
any way to get pressure against the pawn
okay interesting this is funny someone
just goes wasn't there friction between
Danny and Hess I don't know if we've
ever had friction everybody you know
depending on who you're dealing with in
the chest community some some I think
struggle a little more with our
sarcastic sense of humor but they don't
know that for us it's just pillow talk
you know yeah you know the song how deep
is your love
well right it's like an ocean right and
and our love is not just water under the
bridge
thank you shout out to chess play her
favorite Adele song and she doesn't
think I pay attention to her in chat you
know okay well lavon's sitting tight as
you said the knight on d5 blocking
further pressure from arriving at the e6
pawn but okay look out for again I I
like to look at the the bigger picture
of where the game is headed from from
knowing what the format of these of this
matches the time control the fact that
at some point it will become an issue
and I look at the fact that blacks King
is potentially weak even though right
now it doesn't seem so with so many
pieces crowded around I don't know I get
a little bit more nervous about blacks
position than then maybe others right
here and the fact that he's down a
minute on the clock has me a little
worried yeah that time situation is
great for Fabi but he needs all the time
he can get as we've seen he's been
blundering away stumbling fumbling in
short time stretches when he just has
ten seconds on the clock he's he's the
one making the critical blenders LaVon
is the woman who's taking in the full
point chess made just speculated about
another purpose of lavon's light that I
won't say on camera but interesting
okay sorry Bishop III to the chess I I
totally missed that I wish I had seen
but with a bit on b3 you can always
capture this knight on d5 I would never
rush that capture some people say oh
maybe I can get good knighting as bad
bishop the bishop in d7 as bad as a
current currently sits it's not bad when
it you take on d5 yeah it opens up new
diagonals for it and now you can play
like I said before ideas a take on see
it but h4 I'm just gonna poke and prod
at the King side not wait Knight c3 now
I've been and he played it yeah I like
that move the e6 pawns come after now
the great way to undermine
we'd pause on open files especially if
they've been successfully guarded like
this is to attack in the lead pawn
attend even though this isn't a pawn
here sometimes you might undermine that
with a move like c4 here you're you're
trying to dislodge the knight to do
everything you can to open up threats
against c6 so nice e3 was a nice move so
that you aged for but I think h4 and h5
makes a lot of sense you don't want to
play d5 everybody cuz black will strike
back with E 5 he's not going to take and
open up the position so ok h4 there's
moves like Queen f4 and h5 coming
again time combined with the potentially
weak King here because all these pollens
have advanced I'm again liking Fabiano's
chances whoa h5 was not expecting that I
actually didn't like the move Queen
afore I thought night e 2 to f4 was a
smarter way to play this
she's rewriting that night towards the
kingside 92 to f4 and then maybe even
put the bishop on c2 I like it partner
maybe that would have been better I
think there's still shots of Bishop c2
in a lot of positions because of the g6
pawn yep
so I think we still like Fabiano but
maybe you're right maybe this Knight
relocation was was a missed opportunity
Fabiano needs a win man feels bad man to
be down 3 especially when he started the
match with a victory yep he hasn't won
since the first game hashtag stats and
with only 10 minutes left in the 5
minute portion it's possible this is
their second to last game I don't think
this will be the last game I think will
be the I think probably one more after
this yeah that sounds about right
a pawn is not hanging victory condition
the knight on c7 and the bishop on c8
guarded but g6 is weak so far beyond was
trying that you know what he's probably
thinking about Robert
he's probably considering g4 here maybe
Wow
no okay he plays Bishop c2 but I think
he's looking for something to be
aggressive but that might be some of the
backfires maybe maybe best not to never
go full Danny wrench honestly g4 is an
interesting idea because with the King
King now in g7 g for the brook can't go
to g7 to be up g6 so g4 on takes G for a
queen g4 Knight f5 I can go h5 is white
but then you'll go g5 it's getting kind
of messy on this headboard I mean maybe
there's ideas like d5 if g5 cuz f5 can
be undermined oh I like that too
so I was gonna say the main draw back
into position okay is that you ruin your
pawn structure as Robert he went full
Danny wrench yep h5 we're gonna see your
line I like your idea of h5 and then d5
I think that I think that Fabi gets a
good attack here
okay so h5g five that looks pretty good
h 5 g 5d 5 so let's look at that on the
analysis board what's that what's the
tactics so that for the idea everybody
is if you move this pawn white would
have been winning the night here but
instead fought me on a place 94 okay
that actually threatens knight g3
because the knight on f5 is pinned to
the g6 connection by the Queen and
Bishop it also threatens h5 where you
can't go g5 so I'll take with my Knights
ah Thank You Winston check Hill Winston
check oh what a moment almost as cool as
Winston Churchill but we like it
King h8 here comes h5 or 93 pick your
poison
don't take g6 everybody cuz pins happen
well h5 actually might have been bad
because just G takes h5 and the queen is
gonna get insurance at work h7 yep
always avoid these except in twitch chat
there you go that's your pin Queen g8
okay lavon's defending h5 time now yeah
yeah okay he doesn't go for it he wants
to it's not the worst idea to just sort
of sit tight when your opponent is is
under stress like this everybody cuz you
know in theory the longer they're in a
bad position the harder it is to play
and the more likely they get under time
pressure or blunder but at the same time
that the the counter-argument to that to
play devil's advocate is Fabiano has has
failed to convert on some better
positions a couple times today and you
don't you have to calculate accurately
at some point of White's gonna get this
attack so that's my worry with Bishop e3
is is he gonna get under a minute and
still not have the pressure against this
black king that we've been calling for
yeah I see two ideas here what is if a
queen at four and threading Queen h6
check perhaps some moment or Queen d6
because there's no Pope you have pieces
on blacks Queen side yes if I can put
Queen at four hit tonight on you know on
c7 square if you play 95 I will go my
queen at d6 and
just poking and prodding waiting for the
right moment to kind of unleash my real
plan but look at the clock situation oh
yeah I agree with you but again is we're
getting in the time pressure here and
Fabiano needs to find some pressure you
can see his he's leaned in and focus
look that's the thing when you're
playing blitz you can't just spend 25
seconds at this point in the game spent
53 seconds I'll play them in Queen h3 I
agree
you know intuition is key rather than
trying to find the best move it in many
cases Knight f5 I oh now black has
Knight a for coming in some position you
have to watch out engage - he wants to
get the G file g5 just go g5 you can't
take because there H file is even a
knight age four and then g5 after queen
g4 he's gonna play chief 5 no 9 h5
what's he doing he's just you know what
the tables have turned in and and LaVon
is saying I'm not gonna change anything
about this because Bobby's the one under
time pressure now we have Queen g6 Angie
fall oh there was queen to c7 check
perhaps and then I go Knight e5 me I
don't know I see lots of calculate but
95 look like now King f1 maybe no king
of one there's Bishop a6 you can't run
the King out Wow
LaVon is defending this position could
be a huge one only five minutes left in
five minute and White's position is
terrible I've got all these weak pawns
no this is terrible something completely
backfired therefore Fabiano struggling
to convert on his pressure where he
could could even 95 there the g6 pawn
was vulnerable I think you miss Knight
c2 e 501 of the 95 I'm back up on the
analysis board to show everybody your
idea cuz I like it that much if 95 takes
shake-and-bake g6 is a problem maybe
that was probably on his last chance at
this once well now we're an endgame
where it looks like it should but it
looks like black shouldn't lose right I
mean okay you can't overlook the rook d7
doesn't it know then you can take on the
food with the rook down okay so so black
black really shouldn't lose this despite
being down only five seconds why did
Fabi not take the 94
take and take f6 I think he thought he
had some sort of mating net against the
King on the H file
okay well this looks like ya don't Jake
b5 that would have been 90 to turn to
you - King bee - take that you win a
piece o weave tricks he tricks him the
Brooke got overwhelmed yeah but this is
still probably should be a draw but but
still with only six seconds this is
definitely Fabiano's best winning chance
he's had in and sometime he aged five
yep king of fours
maybe now king of six okay at four you
can take and take on f4 okay can LaVon
hold this we know this should be a
theoretical draw this should be a
theoretical draw but but didn't he broke
g4 there my name is rook g4 was just was
just winning yeah I think it was winning
dudes like what these are weird and yet
these are because the knight and king or
not you can see the computer evaluation
bar has no idea really what's going on
but now it's a draw okay and indeed
Fabiano just accepts it the biggest the
biggest opportunity everybody and one of
the ways to educationally learn how to
win this is you want to separate the
king at night so a move like rook g4 is
what robbers idea is you can't play king
h2 because of check and if you move the
knight to f6 there's moves like rook c5
and then suddenly black is in is in some
sort of zoogs Wang so with that rook g4
Brooke g5 idea that might have been Fabi
on his chance to win now he's gonna be
at best even if he wins this game taking
a three game deficit into the
three-minute portion so another one
another one slips away for the American
yep and he needs the win this cut the
deficit to two points because you know
you can't just be living down three
games and hoping that in a quicker time
controls you'll make things happen
because we've seen as the clock ticks
lower and lower father's play gets worse
although he did just save a tough
endgame he did he did he saved an
endgame a tough one under time pressure
it was hard to say you know maybe poetic
justice the fact that it was a draw cuz
I think both sides had chances to win
that game did you see that what LaVon
has got a nice kiss on the cheek there
oh yeah
tomorrow Yellen mmm-hmm there you go hey
hey he doesn't need a good luck charm
but that he doesn't need a good luck
charm he's
he has his his wifey there supporting
him isn't this position like dominant
here with the white pieces yeah maybe
that's why she gave him a kiss she said
that's my boy take down you take down
that but no nice structure and you take
it down hard well this looks terrible
the e5 happens in the Benoni
and I could use some Bologna seriously
though we're gonna get some lunch after
this and it's a great but no nation
structure for a white because you
haven't committed yourseif on anywhere
normally in these bananas you're left
with a pawn e for that rook can come to
eat an attack there's nothing for white
to it super black to attack here it's
just played Bishop f4 back yep then put
your name even shall they play for d6
well I think if LaVon moves on in this
match I can already say our next our
next match will have an emote with LaVon
but maybe with some red lipstick on the
cheek maybe it's not so bad for blocking
I'm trying to evaluate this I think
we're bonds think about playing d6 here
anybody ssin g3 which is just yeah ok f5
is a move that almost desperate about
the fact that black is really struggling
to coordinate the kingside he'll put the
bishop on f6 probably bring it back to
g7 and try to get the knight to f6 but
still this is a position that just feels
like white is an accurate mover to away
from crushing pre I was gonna say bring
the Knight to d5 and c7 grab the e-file
and feels bad man is awful and no trick
says no Robert please this is pretty bad
yeah it's just like I'm trying to come
up with something from black hair but
this is looking no and only only 4544
less than a minute left the players have
been notified that this is their last
game we have had some stat confirmation
are our team working super hard behind
the scenes thank you to everyone at
chess calm apparently they did just
check that last position because they'd
like us to be as look as smart as
possible apparently it was not it was
not a win there was no missed win for
LaVon or sorry Oh for Fabiano but still
then instructive point for those who
have been with us to separate the rook
in the King and Knight is how you can
win with a king and rook them even
though
it's easier said than done okay um
Queenie - you're gonna put you're gonna
poke the bishop out of d4 put the other
rook over here take on d5 and play
Knight f6 you have to okay did it in
these positions Danny that I've had many
cramps awful positions in a day I just
sometimes you have to unleash and even
if you give white the permanent
advantage these two bishops yeah I guess
interesting he wants you to trade off
bishop so that the dark squares are a
permanent problem I like that move I
like c3 you have rook e8 maybe just try
to keep the bishop I don't know it looks
not great the feels like feels like
LaVon is once the smoke clears here
these bishops will be gone that dark
squares will be weak and the D pawn will
likely still be standing so Fabiano has
his work cut out for him does just
window something here looks really bad
bishop me 694 pawn takes d4 you get rid
of the darks for Bishop so you can place
your Bishop on the e5 square what we
this is a bad choice by favi in this
game yeah I mean not quite as bad as the
French decision for those who missed the
the great debacle of the SCC French
decision it'll go down in history but
here he here he plays a benoni structure
which is equivalent to the French
against d4 I like to say just giving
yourself a worse position and praying
your opponent screws up it's like your
openings used to play those kind of
openings right don't you dare what do
you mean you don't even have openings
bro and you know it's right that's why
the only one don't want you insult but
how can you it's all something you can't
see okay there you go right all right I
see four here Queen c4 Howie Howie Queen
well what does white do here now because
it's a 92 you wouldn't exchange yeah but
it's an exchange sac I mean so much
pressure
the players have been notified let's
make sure that they are also notified
via the chest comm game chat that no
more games to go we'll be ready to abort
in case they miss it sometimes in the
heat of the moment they just keep
playing so I don't know what you play
but I'm playing Bishop c3 Queen d4 and
uh the in-laws are invited to dinner on
g7 and h8 Queen f7 to stop your exact
plan you can't stop my plan you can you
can hope to contain it you can hope to
contain it I've continued okay Bishop c3
i guard back on e1 how are you stopping
my plan what are you talking about each
six or h5 okay Queen d4 1887 thank you
okay way like I said you've contained it
for now but I always say week dark
squares are like inviting the in-laws to
dinner it can't get rid of them you just
make that up right now I've never heard
you say that before I actually have said
that before well I I guess I ignore you
when you saw what you know what hey join
the closest route there literally is a
club for ignoring Dani wrench you can
join it if you want I hope your wife
forgives you yeah okay the other thing
that White has here seriously is b4 b5
and at some point we have a lot of pawns
over here that are about to have become
past what is the deal with New York and
car alarms I mean the stereotype is true
man it's not even a car alarm that
sounds like police I see some lights
outside so I assume the police are
drowning here comes b4 and b5 what does
LaVon waiting for it let's let's let's
bring the heat to the queenside
prepare prepare for the coming of the
pawns winter is coming so when can I go
b6 it doesn't help right here just
enough before and you wait so if I go b6
you go before I go a5 can I somehow
undermine your pawn structure oh you'd
like that wouldn't you I needed to do I
usually think that's a good I like that
idea
okay Bobby brings the rook d2 and maybe
this whole exchange SEC is not as sexy
as I thought but it is okay I think that
white is still in control even if I
can't just get c6 I have rook f3 rook g3
it feels like this is going to be
positioned at under time pressure Robert
Black has a very hard time balancing
protecting the King on h7 and dealing
with
the passports yeah this looks really bad
i three thought you shouldn't be six in
85 but perhaps are just losing yo matter
anyway it's just yeah the material
doesn't mean as much here hello wait
what if I go rook eath no is the Vaughn
just brush his shoulder off again go on
Russia shoulder off the he's probably a
jay-z fan we'll ask him that but I bet
he loves rap so okay Bobby down to 30
seconds left so Livan up two minutes on
the clock with a beautiful attack a
beautiful pawn storm on the Queen side I
don't even know what to do here is black
you better hope they like you go f4 and
some on a sack on h3 and it works out
because I don't see anything else we're
gonna talk a little bit at the break of
course about everything we've seen so
far as soon as this game is over there
will be a couple minutes of Robin and I
breaking down what we've seen as we
prepare for the three-minute portion of
today's match so don't go anywhere
it's it's only just beginning because
our stats not to this degree Robert but
our stats sort of said that LaVon was
favored in five minute but that Fabiana
was the better three minute player so
far does that make sense it makes sense
based on their previous performances in
said time controls don't argue you know
that there are lies and then there are
statistics learn how to reads into
statistics you're gonna come and salt me
I don't like that no I wasn't I wasn't
insulting you I was loved it was
creative criticism isn't Queen takes the
truth hurts Queen takes b7 Queen to g7 I
think Fabiano has problems here okay you
can play Bishop g7 the idea everybody is
that that would completely prevent King
age 7 now you give discovered check and
you've taken away the g5 escape square
but the okay LaVon decides I don't need
to take it away I'll just chase him to
g5 Bishop to c1 is coming and if f4 rook
d5 I think it's lights out yep Rick d5
ends iam the spot here well if King H
forwards tomaters haven't seen it yet
just Bishop takes up four maybe okay
yeah rook d5 King age four Bishop takes
up four oh he doesn't go for that
I think that was more accurate okay
so he mini crook t5 fish before was game
over so LaVon maybe maybe made himself a
gave himself a little more work to do
now
okay he's trying to bring the Queen
around yeah bring the Queen back to f3
and when the F pause this is actually a
very smart and safe decision there
instead of going for anything crazy like
h4 check which probably was winning but
do something like this oh nice
just it's very very straightforward
Fabiano immediately just gets up doesn't
really want any part of sitting in his
chair anymore given that we are
currently looking at what are we looking
at we're looking at a four friggin game
lead heading into three-minute Robert
we're gonna take a quick a quick break
and I'll be right back to discuss and
preview the three minute portion don't
go anywhere everybody well as we said
the stats predicted a slightly stronger
performance for Levon Aronian in the
five-minute portion but if you had asked
anybody whether either player would have
a four game lead heading into the free
minute portion I think the answer would
have been no and rightfully so as we
take a look at the current trajectory of
this match it's all of on Aronian so I'm
gonna put the pressure on you Robert and
say you're in st. Louis with the world
championship challenger you're in his
camp
what advice are you giving him right now
how are you helping him shake off the
last portion and just focus on what's
ahead well you just say play more
quickly because you've been getting
yourself in time travel and spoiling
good positions and it's a matter of
conversion and there's been an element
of not being uncertainty not knowing
when to push your pawns and to actually
just spring open the position because
he's been getting plenty of good
positions Fabiano has and stop playing
openings like the French of the Nonis
those are the main piece of advice ya
cannot play that against someone of
Levana brains prowess he loves space
he's a great very creative player but
you're making it way too easy for him if
you're giving him all the benefits of
the position and then trying to make
magic happen up in there
well and given that we had Livan at a
favorite as a favorite heading into this
match here you can see that right now we
we feel like Fabiano really has this
work cut out for him given what we've
seen under time pressure and that in
Bullitt that's only gonna get worse but
ok what what's up ahead is is the
players getting set and they have
retaken their seats or at least one of
them has we will be starting the
3-minute portion
momentarily you heard the advice from
Coach Hess stop playing bad openings
right forget the past and stop playing
bad openings focus on what's ahead of
you right yep
let's do it let's do it let's do it time
for the games to begin and and they have
here we go go Celtics yeah I can't do a
commentary with you anymore if you're
gonna be ready for the Celtics I'm sorry
you know I think most people in New York
root for the Celtics at this point do
you want it do you want to put you on
the therapist chair you want to get it
out how you feel about the Knicks it's
patently false that New Yorkers would
never work for the Celtics get here
alright well I don't know about you
Fairweather fans out in Arizona Oh
calling out the Fairweather fans that's
cuz it's nice outside so you're right
we're Fairweather fans cuz we got no I
got no need to do when our teams are bad
you have like a college basketball team
as in the NBA and so and you know out
there in Phoenix I don't know what to
say about y'all Bobby has has leaned
into a relaxed pose with only his hair
visible as we can say one day maybe he
considers growing corn rolls are rolling
himself some corn rolls but that would
be something hey look at Fabi playing
you know I see a 19 f4 which indicates
to me that he played III 92 and these
positions quite solid for both sides
white tries to get this Carlsbad
structure right look at the queenside
you have the four on three from in
blacks favor but the palm minority
attack and a Carlsbad structure is very
commonplace now Bishop d6 from Black is
always an option keeping an eye on the
three square there it goes for Benny
four and looks like father just set up
in this chair as I said that and yeah so
right now looking like black is a very
pleasant position f-for not a move you
want to play considering the setup you
have it on that three one plate efore
but now that the bishop and the Queen
lined up in the h2 upon the position
definitely is favoring black here I'd
hate see well actually now ninety five
might get that rook into some trouble
there the rook may have overstayed his
welcome welcome on the e-file because
that's ninety five f6 I'm just quite
Bishop d3 and sacrificing shape the two
pieces for the rook yeah with a very
very strong potential attack on the F
file something like this and F takes e5
should be compensation for white to have
attacking chances even though black has
two pieces for the rook yep and we're
gonna see exactly that so look at you
predicting the plan sometimes the Von's
on the plate you take set for that's why
he's thinking ah throwing it right back
at you second the exchange if black
takes f4 white has to move the bishop
and then black might even take again on
e3 with frets on h2 although at this one
it's hard to tell who's King is gonna be
more weak if that type of position
occurs Robert with the F file being open
and potential light Square meetings on
h7 whoa in fact on that note I think
that's why he takes on d4 he want he
wants no part of opening up this rook on
f1 keeping I really like he takes up for
playing f3 afterwards just to continue
breaking over the open position but
maybe I was and probably I was missing
something so I mean I don't see full
compensation here I think that black has
some initiative especially because you
have the four on two now on the Queen
side yep but white has two bishops open
space to work with I'll consider it
should be four it just played of course
right putting your bish when a better
diagonal yep
now you can even play Bishop e5 there it
goes you can't take me because if I take
with a pawn I'd be at file your pin I
could click Queen d4 next I'm firmly
controlling all of the dark squares in
the position this is amazing for a while
yeah and and up the exchange the other
row comes to e1 we've already
got open files for for the rooks to flex
their muscles that's what you need if
you have a rook versus a minor piece I
agree white is in complete control here
and for those asking why Fabiano is not
in complete control of his webcam we do
our best to let them know maybe maybe
one of his Grandmaster friends there
on-site can is listening to our show and
can conduction but when these guys are
focused we don't want to bother them but
they do tend to eventually realize that
they're not on camera yep so which is I
turn away to eat a bite of an energy bar
all of a sudden I see a pawn on f5 yes
we played a5 yeah I think this is fine
white just maintaining the bind still
have the battery here now maybe you're
gonna play b5 in some positions to
undermine the D pawn but yeah okay rook
e1 White's it's tight
b5 shots are in the air
I might even play b5 here if b5 takes I
take up 6 and then gobble d5 with Chuck
well you won watch offer you one right
if you ever move your b5 takes takes up
6 you're really gonna take me one there
yes I guess you are I was kidding back
rank problems and Fabiano agrees with
you and decides to defend he won my bad
I was actually just testing you you
barely passed
f+ I've been to college in a few years
but I could still take a test every now
and then yep okay I still like b5 at
some point though for Fabi and we'd like
him to get his his his first win in a
long time here has not won since the
first game of the match for those of you
just joining us Caruana jumped out to a
lead but it has been all Armenia ever
since
yeah Knight g4 now you're going for a
king side initiative the pawn on b4 is
very weak yeah
hmm takes trade taking shake-and-bake b5
I'm slightly like blacks chance is more
and more I mean without the pieces on
the board I well and now you can't play
b5 because of trades even rugby one
fails to be for the bishop on f8 defense
so he's okay so he's gonna prepare b5
but I agree is b5 met by c5 and suddenly
Black has two passers you 5 c5 yeah
Fabiana has let pressure slip he does
have a time edge but I feel like we're a
bit of a broken record saying lack of
execution and better positions right now
and then eventual time pressure is doing
Fabiano in it does a good position but
clearly black is the one been making
progress in recent moves play h3 here 95
I'd play for black st. okay there it
goes if you take on e5 that the Bishop
and pawn is good against the rook now in
that came with c4 it's it's a knight a3
put that nine on b5 wait the rubies hung
what oh my gosh Fabiano just leaned back
shook his head very frustrated not even
on camera right now just absolutely
absolutely upset and we see the Vaughn
hasn't moved a muscle and quite some
time no need to with a five game lead
Fabiano leaning back in we he does exist
the hair exists anyway the hair is real
man he disappeared I mean I just lost
sight of him for a little while there at
this point we might need an emote of
just Fabiano's forehead and fro what do
you think like big war they might get
more people spamming his emote if we get
the the forehead and fro going okay
what's going on here this looks terrible
for black Wade isn't native fight you
can't stop 905
Danny yeah I really don't like this
position I think that Fabiano is on a
bit of a tilt right now Bishop g5 isn't
just winning the D fight yeah this is
he's just in big trouble
nice he's just he's just uh just not in
the best of shape right now
so with still some time left in the
match there's obviously time to
potentially recover but right now our
our pre match prediction is looking more
right than we ever could have predicted
given the the trajectory of this match
despite the only of being a 68% favorite
right now LaVon is is really in control
yeah this is just brutal now White's up
a clean pawn has a nice bishop
okay go rook d7 try to go rook da and
hope that you can somehow survive here
you get do get some counter play now in
the d3 pot so I don't know if I like
what just happened for white consider
how great the position was because net
okay you can't take on f3 because take
on f3 check out d3 there's a rookie a
check back rank problem where it should
eat 4 check with a followed suit as well
so that was a nice little tactical shot
possible for onion and here if you trade
Queens well not a DJ font is better
protected than it was before so yeah and
it's a clean pawn I mean I agree with
you I feel like white potentially had
more of an advantage there out of the
out of the middle game transition to the
endgame but he's up a clean pawn he'll
double rooks on the e-file and kind of
grind this one home it's a tough one to
be Fabiano here and look at the rating
situation Levon about to get to 3,000
yeah hey kar Nakamura here he comes
what is the cars rating carros blitz
rating I don't know somebody will
somebody will bring us those stats here
in just a moment but I would say that
hey Carla's rating is probably over 3100
if I had to guess Wow if I had to guess
that's pretty high again don't know if I
can count that high yeah I stopped
counting that high in middle school
so so let's see what can black do to
survive and these positions are very
instructive I feel like because yeah as
white you're up a paw and you've the
bishop you know that you're better of
converting this can be quite difficult
so now I would take on a fourth but yup
the decent oven rook a to d7 okay plays
a five but the risk now is that this
Bishop establishes itself on b5 if
guards both a4 and d3 yeah I actually
wait but you can't go to b5 rook c7 you
go Bishop e5 Knight d5 oh I missed that
rook c7 yeah so LaVon likes my
positional idea but just like me he
blunders in calculating I told you never
go full Danny yeah but this the reason
we said that everybody though playing
these types of men games as Robert said
finding a long term goal despite the
extra pawn it's gonna be work for white
so when you have ideas like where to put
your pieces if you can put your pieces
on the right squares to protect the
weaknesses it allows you to focus on on
improving the position but but here
Bishop c6 turned out to be a tactical
blunder and black has gained some
critical time to have a more active King
so rook e1 as possible here because that
the knight a Ford there's always rupees
seven check so I would play rook b1 an
aim to go to the B 5 square you have to
essentially admit that you're gonna lose
you're a pawn or it's temporarily
sacrifice it they don't really just play
you know because you can't just let the
position sit how is white gonna make
progress if you you know don't do
anything and you keep attached your a4
pawn then black will just sit as well
for d6 I was gonna say black is doing
more than sitting with rook d6 cuz there
was a threat of rook F 6 but Fabiana
decides he doesn't like it plays worth
v8 so now for p1 Knight takes a form a
trip back to a1 as possible that's
something that you can always consider
as something like that but he's playing
on the Kings side now okay so Bishop d5
just to hit the f7 pawn strong
I think he's smartly sort of playing
tickle here he's just up a pawn knows
maybe he didn't have the best technique
clearly whenever you play and move like
Bishop c6 and backup as we saw earlier
but but okay that he made a new weakness
and he's gonna infiltrate the e6 or le7
depending on where you can't defend the
entire efile with the pawn f7 you can go
King g6 the rook
find me a place to land on now by
playing f6 the world will come to e6 if
you favor be 600 maverick to e7 or e
yeah yeah come around and poke at these
pawns and again if black loses sight of
any sort of blockade at some point let's
not forget we have an extra D pawn in d3
and white will just play d4 and create a
passer passers not to be confused with
pot confused with pot sirs I think d4
now is actually already in the air
although you don't want to allow take
stakes and rook before forking the two
pawns everybody so LaVon still just kind
of sitting tight now threats of rookie 7
and 2h7 are in the air because h6 is a
permanent weakness so here here Robert
is it time for something like okay okay
tell everybody how you would evaluate
the Brooks coming off the board here so
if I sell the rooks coming off the board
I would point out that what you just
mentioned there's a pawn on h6 that
needs to be captured because I have upon
h-bar cementing in its place and this
looks like a blunder from LaVon but the
king on d6 actually hits that bish 1 d5
is it oh but it isn't a blunder you can
play rook h7 exactly rook aged 7 so it
looks like you're losing a piece but
yeah Brooks slides away in your yep full
safety but now look f8 is the question
may come do I want to trade rooks the
answer is no you do not yeah and the
reason why you don't is because look at
the pawns for black they're on the dark
squares yeah that means a king can slide
in but the bishop can never attack those
Pope so if I trade these ropes and
didn't try to make progress but I know
you don't have to I guess okay yeah yeah
you keep these rooks on as long as
possible because if you do trade then
you're gonna very difficult time
actually attacking pause your own extra
pawn is this D pawn but my king is in
time to blockade it yeah and that's a
very bad thing about having a bishop in
the endgame is that you cannot force a
king a LightSquared bishop cannot force
it came off a dark square yeah so you
know you answered exactly what I was
hoping for some educated teaching
moments by Bobby Hess everybody wears
the jingle you know and evaluating what
pieces you may or may not to come off
the board you have to think about
long-term goals and his Robert pointed
out white doesn't want an endgame where
he can't target a whole bunch of pawns
with the light square bishop but with
the rooks on the board he is
targeting those pawns he finds a way to
win another and not only is he winning
another pawn he may win another game
shout out to our last twitch prime sub
thank you so much anybody's got twitch
prime laying around just click the sub
button it's free to you so why is he
just playing tickle polka now Ron Ron
here comes Rick a six
he's win a piece yes he did
oh that's a knight and with it that's
the game Fabiano on tilt needs to pull
himself together he knows it the fans
know it our subs know it thanks for the
twitch prime subs coming in they be
rolling in Robert we have a six game
lead for Aronian yeah it's become very
one-sided and Fabiano is now switching
it up from his London system into this
red tee opening right place c4 is gonna
try to gain space in the center but
LaVon classical player he is he's played
this from the white side he knows how to
play from but look at this move rook g1
I really like that decision because now
it doesn't matter that you're playing
well and losing you are playing well
which he hasn't been but you just have
to win game did you ever do memes and I
hope my students are not watching me and
hearing me say that because I always
tell them which is true I much prefer
you make good moves over good results I
don't want me to play a bad game and win
I want you to play as well as possible
at every turn
and right now Fabio just needs a wins
then it's 8 to 2 this is the incredibly
lopsided couple if your students ever
get in an SCC match we'll give them
permission to do that too so I didn't
know people actually paid you to talk
about chess you've been doing this for
free for us for years
haha lying to the public lol yeah Robert
has is a free chest commentary for hire
reach out Joe yeah nice lies okay so the
the knight comes to e4 here comes chief
for I know but jokes aside I agree with
what you've told your students but I
also agree with Bobby's decision just
like you do and I think I think we got a
got to be all-in maybe Queens c3 to
defend e4 I don't think you can just
sack the D pawn yeah he does it and now
again look for g4 look for this to be an
exciting game done the Nunda nonetheless
you know regardless of them
f-score bobbies up 30 seconds and going
for the attack but now the queens are up
but I don't like what just has happened
here for whites point of you I thought
you could've got a little more by
trading the Queen's an a5 I thought that
might been premature he could have
played with a d5 first to hit that night
those on c6 cousin I need for protecting
the Queen
so now White's piece they're a little
bit awkward you have this knight on e4
again a good-looking piece but at some
point of rook will come to Ian kick it
from I think you should play Knight to
d4 for white get a second night in this
game but Black has controlled the f4
square the part on g4 is a little bit
overextended so I really liked how this
game has progressed from Livan yeah
despite the fact that his his Knights
are a little bit awkward for the time
being and time suggested to Fabiana
takes his first real think of the game
maybe not thrilled with how he
transitioned either decides his best
chance is to push the D pawn maybe bring
it into d7 and go for some magic there
yeah so let's see d7 the point is let's
take on d7 and then take a new force
that 94 is hanging which means d7 does
not win a piece for white but what else
can you do because move a knight c3
which he end up playing Bishop d7 I
think black is consolidating
coordinating and I'm gonna scoop up this
d6 pawn okay
maybe white has King F 1 and Bishop e5
before you fully coordinate obviously
the bishop there isn't ideally placed
black can play for a 6 and b5 to kick it
out at some point but you do you do have
some help for the D pawn ok 94 though
but now ya know now the D pawn is
falling maybe night b5 a six-night c7 is
his idea well maybe five you always a
Bishop c4 stuff as well because
sufficient e2 is pin yep and now they're
just rook takes d6 is a free opponent
right
LaVon wants more than the pony prevents
rookie 3 because of Knight g2 Fork
that's it should be 5 now your idea just
discovered checks don't work because
although Bishop d7 discovered check
works yeah your bid Bishop d7 was for my
king over to everyone and I got to keep
my D pawn yeah
yeah he goes for it agreed town
population you and Fabi we may still see
Bishop e7 anyway and not necessarily to
trade on b5 but to play a six try to
make the bishop make a decision at some
point yeah I I like this approach from
LaVon he's just sitting tight a little
bit gonna make sure he can surround the
d6 pawn so tonight at five now maybe
night at five I have my knight from a
five at some point coming back into c4
to help out though not right away if not
have five nice c4 I think rook d4 wins a
piece yep so yeah and if you go g6 is
black I'll throw my name east seven
would check put my Brooke on there three
and kick your knife from you have four
square because that's uh would work but
there's rook takes e7 in some of those
lines because of major key one me
clever uh-huh rookie three so Brooke II
to d8 just go after the d6 pawn yeah
ninety-seven and ninety-four doesn't
work again because of rook takes e7
everybody watch out for mates wait but
then the knight protects the d1 rook
Oh ninety-four you're saying oh you
you're setting me up here how's that
wait my nice protecting my rook then you
I've I've been setting you up this whole
time baby then why am I still single
[Laughter]
loves it yeah you're single by choice
we're gonna talk about that off air
right now
okay King g7 okay here comes g5 g v fix
the pawns no he wants rookie four if say
Knight six maybe just please f4 f4 K
rookie four gonna kick the night and if
nice c6 you happily trait and gobble a6
so Fabiano has worked his way back into
the game here even being down on time
here under a minute I'm liking it
yeah this is looking really nice now for
what bit 94 yeah 94 feels really good
because f5 is not possible within the
night night on e7 protecting the square
look at 94 rook takes a seven yeah pawn
takes e7 didn't have a move King e 2 at
the end what you take on D and there was
no way to stop Queen everybody so I
think he might be missing what what yeah
why not 94 why is he giving the b6 the
d6 pawn that was just a blunder I wonder
if he'd forgot that you can't take on e7
there he's just overlooking simple
tactics I mean I wouldn't be surprised
at this point given that he's really
struggling but this that just seems like
such an obvious oversight I mean I saw
that even before you gave the line it's
you know hey it's terrible I mean
Fabiana is playing extremely poorly
right now and credit to LaVon because
LaVon has been playing once played
extremely well and combined that with
right now what has definitely been a
tough day for Fabiano and that's why we
have a six-game lead that is there
blundering of a piece here 96 play play
a 5 and a 3 is that gonna work out he
sacks the exchange tries to rush the
pawn looks like okay so LaVon plays one
of his first blunders of the match right
there
people are party people have already
clipped your why am I still single line
just so you know well you know I just
had to say it scanned of mine okay
probably best play is a draw now cuz the
a pawn is gonna fall 2 nights for the
against the rook okay okay I'll take
that back the two nights are really much
more dangerous than then maybe people
first think because even with all the
pause being equal the Knights really
thrive in this type of position where
everything's on one side of the board
they're gonna maneuver they're gonna
poke they're gonna prod and everyone
hates Forks
no one likes forking under time pressure
nope well that man didn't you know
nevermind you are you are you forking
with me right now don't do it I love I
love putting thoughts into your head
knowing that you can't say most of them
one of my favorite things to do to you
why didn't you put his King to e5
so black should win this game yeah at
this point there's too many weaknesses
in all series
and the Knights are it's only a matter
of time before the knight from f/4
relocates to e5 and f3 is gonna fall 93
was probably winning right there I don't
know why your loved ones waited so long
to play Knight G 695 feels good man go
for a 19-6 95
okay King D 2 or King here after rook a3
you're gonna block with 93 this is just
this is just painful painful to be in
Fabiano shoes right now he wanders the
brook and with it another one bites the
dust LaVon is in complete control of
this match with only 35 minutes to go in
the three minutes not well okay so we're
about halfway through the match right
now as far as total games plate there's
we're a little more than halfway through
the match as far as time on the clock
but the average games played per time
control this is about the halfway mark
so the tides must turn now Frodo
well you made a Queen reference and I
was wondering if you're as excited for
the movie coming out as I am but you
know I don't know not all of us see 12
movies a week like you so Wow okay way
to just call me out my crazy today you
know hey we're here to have fun and you
tell everybody how proud you are to see
somebody movies a week tell me bout your
movie task I love having my back to the
chests Levon Aronian in control right
now I kind of feel bad for foggy at this
point 92 that's that was not expected
and what is it four straight wins for
Levon now yeah he was at five to two
notes ninety-two look this position
right now is also very nice for white no
weaknesses to speak of there are great
for chess because know why can't just
continue maneuvering at some point you
can consider as white trying to launch a
King side attack it is difficult because
well there's a no pieces for white on
that side of the board not a lot of
minors but the you're right in this
structure because it's so straight
forward at some point you can use the
e-file for a Brooke lift black played f6
there to overprotect d5 preventing the
knight from using the square but but the
more those pawns push even though
there's a lot of a lot of smoke right
now when it clears out look for East six
to be a weakness for black and that
might be a real problem if white plays
f3 here yeah I like a3 a lot actually I
feel like Fabiano is he's in that
aggressive mode Robert where he's
overextending he played Brooke she won
last time is white he wants this attack
but essentially this is a structure that
greatly favors white because the e6 pawn
is weak these pawns are overextended and
black has done nothing to do a minority
attack which is what you normally want
here with B 5 and a 5 right yep and I
like that decision by Bobby a go 96 to
c4 because he's trying to close down the
Queen side and say my pawn on c4 takes
care of your pawn on b2 since the pawns
on a3 if that power on a - you could
play b3 and chisel yeah but even so I
mean yeah I agree it it simplifies the
queenside problems but you're just
getting into a position where to look at
LaVon I mean he's just the e6 pawn is
weak the the black King is potentially
open here I don't know if we're playing
anything that does it like queen h7 I
guess not yet but I agree with you but I
just feel like white is playing for 2
results already in this position yeah I
like to remove Queen h7 Danni because
you know threat it makes threats in the
position your queen can go from h5 @ g4
put pressure on these six pawn the thing
is it's actually hard to make progress
though fer for white unless you play a
move like g3 which perhaps now what
about h4 here
h4 as well as an option in place Queen
e2 first but I'm looking at this idea to
undermine the protection of the F pawn I
like g3 more because in play h4 I'm
gonna go rook h8 at some point and look
you might regret opening the file and
when g3 agrees with you another good
reason why your move is better Robert is
this leaves these G pawns doubled and
isolated right because you got rid of
the f1 so I agree yeah g3 was nice and
now white might even play Bishop e5 yeah
there are a couple options here you can
play f4 just to open up more lines and
say that despite getting rid of those
ugly double pawns you're keeping black
stuck and my playing f4 you open up the
F file for your rook and you could take
with f4 GF for work takes up for maybe
swing your other row to the F file and
say that I'm just gonna continue piling
up pressure here he started with rook g4
I think black should try to rip each
beat because you need to make you need
to do something active and hear f4 again
speaks to me but
I saw some comments asking for cameras
from the players but as we can see
they've been off the webcam as their as
their intensity picks up and
frustrations mount for the American he's
sort of he sort of been stuck to his to
his afro view we'll call this the fro
view so that's why that's why we haven't
been showing too much of them on camera
the H files open Robert the idea you
said is is potentially going to be there
though yeah I think he could have also
played with the H on being openly this
work H 5 to f5 just to come to the
defense of your position yeah but I
already I already like to specially more
for black and I did earlier why it
should still be slightly better the bish
one it for always guards h2 so you're
not really too worried about an attack
on the kingside quite yeah yeah but now
look at five bring your other work to f7
you may compete for the f5
I agree yeah no this is this is better
than I felt the position was headed
toward shout-out to our last two subs mg
T 3 thank you for the tier 1 sub thank
you for our last prime sub appreciate
the support I'm actually Danny also in
an end game like let's say we trade all
the heavy pieces yeah look at queenside
Paulo yeah no these are a bunch of Paul
and stuck on dark squares in this Bishop
starts licking his lips yeah no Fabiano
has this could be a huge win if he
turned this around because this is one
that I was calling earlier that Levon
was already playing for two results so
if I'm if I'm proven wrong about that
I'd be happy because it means we have a
closer match a five and B for perhaps
you know the B 4 will come at some point
but in certain end games I actually
liked not having my pot on the a5
because my king could slip through a
four yeah very nice foresight and yeah
now did you do this you have to play put
you up on a B 4 but offering some of
these trades for example 8 takes before
and now rook a8 ok 1 you don't have the
access that you have you a moment ago
and that's a great point Robert yeah it
was a very instructive point for those
who are paying attention and trying to
learn during these shows by Robert
thinking of that long-term plan of
bringing the King around to the pawn
structure here Fabiano if you look at
the position now all of a sudden White's
pieces have broken free yep
it and so actually key you could take c3
here that we have funny blender if you
over takes you for my King Forks erupts
yeah that would have been sweet let's
look at that on the analysis board shout
out to smarter chest for gifting that
last sub thank you that's not something
you see every day not the king moving
like a knight but the king forking the
rook so okay didn't happen
LaVon does not blunder he could have
taken the e6 pawn that was hanging he
six king defy rook back to e3 I agree
with you I think the point was he G was
worried at King b5 but I'm worried about
the black King getting checkmate after
rook 88 for example over K six okay so I
don't know 18 seconds perhaps LaVon just
didn't have the time to calculate it
yeah wait Bishop takes d4 well he's
gonna have to take on c3 don't get mated
you can guard a5 I think yeah I was
gonna say King a4 is fine because you
can block the made on the a file with
the Brooke on f5 so Bishop c3 is and
Fabiano is actually feeling very
confident LaVon goes into the think tank
here he's turned the tables with one
spending all of his time left
I said fabulous feeling comfortable cuz
for a brief glimpse I actually saw
Fabiano's glasses and said hey there's
that guy he might get his first win in a
very long time okay can you actually win
us so you just keep going can be five or
be a check work back to c8 how do you
okay place what before and now here
comes King b3 back the bishop up pushing
baby broke up six pin that Bishop rook
up six pin the bishop I agree Fabiano
move right yeah because if you move your
up from before the broken a three check
comes you lose the C pawn move
grandmaster move he found it he found it
yeah yeah forgave the bishop or were a
for R okay for goes for a mating Nets
uh he why'd he give a check don't give
it a check a play Rick what why is he
giving up the C pawn he has some ideas
of checking this game more check so why
the kingdom then rook f5 check but it
look at six saves the rook for now he
can take d6 but look at the quarter he
does know right
the bishop the King can't beg you back
the King gotta get back he's gonna win
the H pawn and queen with the Jeep on so
he does win LaVon knows it and throws in
the towel Caruana gets his first win in
more than 90 minutes Robert and I'm
giving a shout out to me Ron Schara for
this opening choice here a little bit of
the Vienna hybrid I grew up with Mir and
share always my coach and Meara taught
Fabiana for several years and this was
this throws me back to my childhood
yeah and I guess back to father's as
well but here Black is pulling a very
solid set up wait what amigo Bishop e6
where I can always swing the Queen to d3
or play B 3 and just say I'm gonna try
to use this open D file the pressure the
d6 on the black actually just quite well
in these lines
there's no rush from blacks point of
view you can get two opposite colored
bishops and play a three yep you take on
c3 so you can also put Bishop c5 right
away from black you don't that
necessarily trade but white eventually
would like to play it for f4 and try to
open the position that well I appreciate
how well you know this structure because
certainly Miran sure being a coach that
both you and Fabiano had at some point
in your careers gives you that gives you
that thing in common okay Bishop c5
Fabiano after winning that last game
immediately sat up Robert and shows us
that he he does live but ok we'll see if
Fabiano can use his childhood
coach chess coach and childhood chess
friends energy here with Robert Hess
we're gonna see if some of you know how
to use Photoshop actually we just had
our first idea for a speed chess
championship contest in a while you can
just tweet at me text me call me
actually only tweet at me everybody use
the hashtag speed chess and use
Photoshop to throw something funny on
top of Fabiano car Wanda's afro we can
see the live game there to our left
don't worry you're not missing any
action we're gonna give away a one year
diamond membership for the best
Photoshop of Fabiano car Juana's fro for
head and fro Photoshop contest there you
go
I like it you know you gotta use the
hashtag speech s for a one-year Diamond
membership give us some Photoshop of
Fabiano car want us fro you can include
his face or just the forehead and throw
your call whatever you think is the most
fun I think it's hairs been growing on
us say throughout the match yeah that
hashtag speech s is being used although
not always for the right reasons you
know what they say great power great
responsibility very true and here white
is actually gaining in this position
because if you take on that for and I
take with my bishop on it for at some
point I'll try to play c5 black is a bit
passive here and so you know coming up
with an exact strategy is not easy okay
just like Queen f3 maybe now I don't
care if you don't care if I take it I
want to save that Bishop for potential
potential dark square things but I felt
like I just have more space so if you
even if you take my bishop on up for any
one Bishop III feels a little slow but
perhaps is also good
yeah the Wendy for what's it
attacking huh I don't know so h4 I guess
that might answer the question so not h4
I like h4
hmm yeah this is looking more and more
into a Jewish territory if he took on
that fate so he plays rook e1 keeping
his options open
he's a bit more flexible with the
additional space a black ever plays c5
you do keep the kick the bishop off of
this long diagonal but you also weaken
their d6 pawn and I just have to give a
shout-out to my good friend our
attackman new Keon because I did just
receive a message from him and as we
know he was the manager behind the
protest League winning team dear me and
the Eagles also isn't a pawn hanging
yeah it is hanging because if Queen
takes everybody east six Falls so unless
LaVon has something with Queen d5 maybe
for King right
you know maybe Funko shortly after
midnight though yeah our talk just sent
me a message on Twitter on twitch -
what's up our talk well now I don't feel
a little special thing well he's rooting
for Armenia clearly here to support his
boy LaVon and by uh Danny I'm confused
you think probably just thinking about
taking on b5 and if there's any but I
think there was Queen d5 like I said at
the end of the light no but then Queen
e3 maybe Knight f4 hitting g2
overwhelming and rookie 4 and I'm
hanging on by a thread don't don't talk
dirty to me Queen d5 Queen e3 Knight f4
rookie 4 I can take g2 and play rook e8
maybe my king my king runs to f3 maybe
weena v h3 is falling too too much to
calculate let's go back to the game yep
we have an analysis board for that
reason I say no and you know I just
you're you're right and I don't want to
say I know hey it's painful I'm as
shocked as you are just like all the
Fabiano fans are shocked about the
performance but Effie Effie is still uh
still using that Fabi
let's go emote okay well right now the
truth is this is really Chow if he's now
under a minute LaVon has defended so far
against against the Bobby Hess Mir on
sheer special but maybe why does h4 and
h5 coming I kind of like done let's do
it does it go let's Opera House is the
same
voices steve kerr i'll tell you as a
compliment it's a voice of reason a
voice of wisdom voice of reason a voice
of wisdom an NBA championship voice
rookie seven rookie rook f7 take it
y'all got nothing draw no take that rook
and go for the a pawn take that rook and
then go for the a pawn okay but i think
black is gonna take with the king and
then c2 would have fallen
perhaps I mean there's you're not wrong
once again you're not wrong hey we all
make mistakes Robert Robert it's
listening fault it's not your fault I
don't I don't want this oh all right
well Fabiano has not lost two games in a
row I feel like we're like the Cleveland
Indians in the movie major-league
Fabiano has not lost two games in a row
that's a good sign
just a bit outside Oh Danny I have a
question for you how much do you think
he has to cut the deficit to have a
chance going to the bullet to four games
I think it has to be within four games
and iced because the predictive analysis
that smarter chess does for us you can
find smarter chess on Twitch just calm
Matt does an amazing job and actually
work super hard he's a mathematician so
he knows what he's doing the analysis
says that LaVon is better under time
pressure and time scrambles and better
and bullet so I you know he was favored
even before this big lead but but I
think if it's within four games anything
can happen because stats are made to be
wrong is that why they're made they
really are actually no I know you're
saying rules were made to be broken
Danny you're stealing pop-culture
references but no stats are made to be
wrong there you go
I like it yeah well this in this
position you know what's wrong is this
Fisher money for because if I don't
Bishop e7 you have to go I guess you
don't have to do anything you're the d5
square neither for coming into d5 me
likey g2 what fiend ketamine midnight
thiing keto the night wants to play
Bishop before perhaps and just take away
one of blacks better Meyer pieces yeah
ricky-ricky aid for black or tripod
you're 95 itself I think I think white
will play for bish before
or maybe play a three queen to a three
just to stop tactic split the Queen on
d2 and then fight fight like heck over
the e-file vjh wants to know if smarter
chess can do odds on Magnus Carlsen
playing a rook down versus Lauren's
Trent L oh I would put Magnus is Audrey
over 70% that gets Trent down a rook
that match was so funny this night 1 G 2
is awful yeah but here he comes
relocation homey here either to f3 or f5
so if you go if I'll take him put my
Brooke on e3 clung mmm actually I'll
take to go g6 and f5 he goes with your
idea maybe g6 and f5 and den Broek e3
was better but but he might have missed
that but Robert I really like your plan
the reason everybody is cuz now with
Roberts rookie 3 LaVon can no wonder
close the e-file with the fish money for
but in the game LaVon did close the
e-file and Fabiano did not have f5 so I
think you're lying with g6 and FY was
better yeah I just I thought what
happens is goes back to e4 I'm not happy
about it somebody's giving up the pollen
he's gonna play c4 of Queen takes no f5o
f5 just repeats I'm sorry yeah I thought
c4 and then threats of Bishop c5 but f5
is more straightforward so if Queen c3
here you know I'm starting to get in
that territory where I'm wondering if if
they might be important anyway now I
would if I'm black I play c4 here
forget the b7 pawn what matters here is
gonna be the initiative and Fabi agrees
can you say two wins in a row I like
black I like c4
I like the opening of the position when
White's King is under mine and this e
pawn is strong Queen D for now serenity
- and the beet soup on turning b2 and
Andy - I love it I love when you talk
about pawns wait can you take on b7
somehow I think you could take on b7 cuz
of back rank mating a attempts it just
feels so really bad but yo Bobby leaning
in LaVon leaning down LaVon leans back
brushes his shoulders off so one of you
a Bishop b4 there wait here's a queen h3
meaning there's some sort of attack
Queen h3 g6 you got nothing right g6
Queen d7
uh-uh oh my gosh Fabiano just leaned in
he he just gave the oh crap I missed
that look yeah cuz Queen d7 comes in
full force and all of a sudden maybe
seven wins a piece everybody
now you've rookie six but then you have
to go to give the f7 pawn that's
terrible f7 is gonna fall f5 is coming
in some positions I so looks like looks
like he clearly missed Queen h3 but it's
not over yet so work up six I guess just
try to you can play Brooke f6 or Queen
f6 cuz even even if you trade Queens the
e3 pawn is still poison yeah he goes
Queen f6 just to get rid of the attack
because III can't be taken but I was
worried about that b7 blinds and is just
gonna capture because when you have an
open King in which Kate well both sides
sort of an open cake but black still
open work SEOs you want to keep the
Queens on the board yes you're gonna
trade it Creon's one will try to go
after the either on at some point soon
played rook to be one but now you've
gained a pawn so white is up upon both
Kings are feel idolatry and if I'm black
I'm gonna go Bishop c7 and b6 and say
well even if you know you can continue
trying to make progress but I don't see
how you're gonna do it
yeah I want to key three pawn is nice
and safe as possible again it's from now
now with black Miss playing and it's
probably best play leads to a draw kind
of result but under a minute neither
side is likely gonna be playing their
best chess so but I agree with you looks
like missing Queen h3 was a huge shot
back in this moment here everybody
missing Queen h3 is where the game turn
from Fabi pushing to maybe LaVon pushing
although this position gonna turn in any
moment yeah as blacks King gets
increasingly safe and white the King
will is still a little bit to worry
about there but you know if that Queen
ever leaves the d5 square for example I
can start using the light squares
yo rook d8 here I think okay with Bishop
c5 how are the white should put upon a6
and at some point continue trying to
make progress in the Queen side but I
don't know how you get this rook active
they were gonna eat to is very much
stuck it's a rookie one now
I one of my questions essentially is if
can I put my king on e2 and just trying
to blockade everything
so rookie one tried it by h5 open the H
file now
I mean lavon's doing everything
correctly I'm impressed by the way he's
handling this game yeah I agree
h5 now for example just you need to
create another weakness and there he
goes h5 it's a trade on c6 play King f3
now your rook can move freely no this is
now is improving White's chances are
definitely oh I don't know about a6
didn't seem necessary but okay it
doesn't really matter that much and a
big reason I don't like to have a six is
you give this bishop this permanent
square on b6 to sit and relax whereas
the Fischer was on c5 the palm is in a5
and rather than okay now this is just g5
go g5 submit that pawn there it is now
play a place Kate rookie I'm trying to
figure out the right way to do this but
black is tied down yep and note if that
palm is on a5 the bishop would not have
this be six squared just sit and relax
on and here's King f3 back
the biggest issue though for y is it's
unless you can dislodge this Bishop then
why is he also tied down to the e pawn
so Bishop e6 and there's gonna be
threats potentially at some point we're
giving itself up for the bishop and then
a7 a8 you know here just c5 okay
straining the rooks off isn't taken e3
but yeah the problems the King can't
move for black so you you create another
pass palm put f5 Bishop takes go g6 then
we can you put the bishop on d6 and c7
is that the only diagonal that holds the
C pawn and targets f4 maybe I don't know
what came after nu is Keaney 4 yeah I
like I like that this is the best
position for the bishop at least for
Fabi sitting on the b8 h 2 diagonal but
it's not gonna be enough yeah yeah f5 is
just so obvious the reason everybody
there's just too much pawns are too far
apart the G and C pawns prevent any sort
of blockade on the dark squares and and
LaVon stops the bleeding after calling
for another win by Fabiano unfortunately
um he misses this really nice move Queen
h3 and the Armenian remains in control
yep control is an understatement for
what's going on here
you know LaVon was very confident I read
that preview then the interviews my
client and LaVon was just saying you
know in his normal joking manner that he
of course is gonna win it all but I
think that confidence really does help
in these formats I know he's out of two
in his first two matches against Chris
Shokan nepo last year yep but he's
played the closest matches pretty much
possible he's lost both games by two
points and now he's showing that he's in
new and improved Levon Aronian with a
huge score in ya know I mean if you're
talking about a statement win although I
know all that matters is winning the
match and I don't think these guys
really carry over or or think too much
about how one of their peers beat
another one because they know what they
have to do on the board but yeah if
you're talking about a statement win
right now Levon Aronian is is doing just
that this has been super impressive
so Levon it's his turn to sort of you
know it's a Kings Indian attack sort of
thing but it has French like position
except the bishop is on h7 so we always
make fun of the French because the
bishop gets locked in here the bishop
releases open and well 998 is a nice
move go to c6 Charlie going to d4 yep so
96 native 3 doesn't stop it now after a
slow go 94 then you want that C foil so
b5 now there's my B 585 a 4 there's the
new attack it was like I don't I I
wonder a little bit I know we're talking
bigger picture here the match still has
plenty of time left but right now I'm
wondering if Fabiano has made some sort
of conscious decision he's not gonna
play his main lines he's in World
Championship prep but something combined
with him playing some dubious openings
and then you lose a few in a row Robert
the rhythm gets away from you and Gloria
Stefan foreshadow tip the rhythm is
getting Fabiano so you're trying to say
you know he's playing a little bit of
hide-and-seek and it's not working out
for him he's been found in the first
five seconds exactly it's like he's
trying and again we talked about the
fact that he bounced around a little bit
to start lost this bad game in the
French but sin
then still it just feels like he's very
rarely I mean at this point if it isn't
a conscious effort to avoid some of his
best opening prep then I worry about it
more I think it's has to be some sort of
effort because he's just not getting
good positions out of the opening period
yeah absolutely and that is a thing you
know we see that also in classical
events not just in speeches championship
yeah when you were preparing for World
Championship match you don't want to
give anything away to your opponent and
that's actually probably a large reason
why Magnus is playing fewer tournaments
yeah I know he's playing be loved
playing the single Cup but he he
declines his grand chest to re-invite
he's not playing in the speed chess
chain just maybe he's just trying to
keep everything as close to the close
the best as possible so here black is
completely winning where it takes a to
where I can just resign as well you're
down upon you're losing b3 do eventually
lose f2 when I go Bishop f5 so this is
you know five does even look like no no
is he not look like the number two
player in the world he's kind of hardly
looking like a grandmaster yeah this
sounds very harsh and I don't mean it to
be like tremendous intelligence this is
not his day yeah everything is looking
off and the score ten and a half three
and a half and this game in particular
that this is probably one of the worst
we've seen it doesn't look like we're
watching a very strong player play chess
well and my client just told us here in
the chest calm behind-the-scenes stat
room that despite winning that first
game Fabiano has not gone back to the
double fianchetto and probably for a
good reason because LaVon adjusted and
look what just happened he just got
crushed as white so he won the first
game with this double fianchetto opening
everybody but probably not because of
the opening as LaVon just showed and um
it's now or never it's now or never it's
either wake up or shake up shake it off
or Taylor Swift it off I don't know what
he's got to do but at this point he's
not looking good
you know his hair is looking good though
yeah they say at this point LaVon might
be on pace to adopting him I don't think
that that's possible if I'll be on a won
a game a couple games ago I pretty sure
official adoption happens at ten in a
row not ten not a ten game lead but
maybe I'm wrong I don't I haven't you
know been adopted in a no kidding I get
adopted every week but uh you know
people people bringing out the little uh
little baby carriages for the adoption
thing it's funny but okay Fabia with the
black pieces now it's kind of sad to see
this be such a one-sided affair I was
very much looking forward to this
matches being over there close one
yep by them well there many more match
to the speeches championships to come so
I guess I have more things to look
forward to in this particular game I
think black by Queen b8 here it's one of
the main ideas as well together Queen
off a D file to protect the b6 bishop
and perhaps start expanding now we we've
seen this position before right yeah we
have we had a we had a Lopez earlier
shout out to our last ape ape trustee
for the for the sub appreciate it yeah
we saw this position and it was one of
the longer games where Fabiana was black
eventually white played b3 and Fabiano
got some counter play on the a file but
something tells me we're not gonna get
the same the same type of approach here
in this one yeah LaVon had played b3 and
then work a d1 here he just went work a
d1 immediately and the bishop was on e6
in that other game hitting the a to pawn
yeah good point that was a big reason
why white had to play B 3 because a2 was
under fire here white did not have to
waste b3 before swinging the rook over
cuz there was no threat and I think
white is in a better spot this in this
game then then LaVon was against Bobby
many games ago so let's say 95 for black
but then okay he's only you just want to
give himself bad pawn structure but he
cans wiped a huge Center yo and what
does black do here you're cramped in you
don't really have space to play d5 I
just got a 5 if you play c5 as black
trying to say well let me
put pressure on your senator then even
just politics t v e5 coming looking good
for white so well now d5 file 194 looks
inviting yeah I see opponents through
700 both both be 5 and d5 our moves here
yeah I agree I see a pawn on c7 though
and I say I have a queen on c1 I'm
making at a backward paw and played d5
yes the d5 was the more positional
approach to try to anchor and I was
wondering if a 5 and opening the bishop
on g6 was okay obviously neither move
happened LaVon opted for them whoa I was
about to say that much more passive 9h
to but he plays f4 dirty girl look at
the yeah I think here comes any mine he
made it seem like he was entering a
docile position there but he's not
peaceful he's not quiet yeah definitely
not gonna allow this these pieces to
stay it the status quo in f4 it's thrown
ef5 you see that the monstrous Center
for white black hasn't really no space
Bishop c8 might be the only move here
which is just a sad one to look at
yeah yeah no that was a bit of a bit of
a shake-up shake-and-bake
convinces us at night h2 is passive
maybe Fabi missed f4 as well given the
time he's taking on the clock
she got out thank you for that sub right
there Chesser sized me in the chest TV
chest as LaVon is working on his tan
that's a tan light that would be another
Photoshop contest though that's just for
fun purposes of lavon's dark light I
thought I was trying to join the boom
man group there you go that too so 95
you see a sacrifice here if you take on
f7 I take with the Queen on f7 I hit the
b3 pawn yeah but behind the bishop on d2
reason tonight and g3 under attack so
this looks great for which the knight
have three now they yet still come to
d4d four and five stolen use your only
chance in positions like this with the
Brooks versus the the minors is quick
pressure of some kind on either open
files or seventh-ranked type of tactics
and it's just black is a far cry away
from that kind of thing so you just have
to love the minors Thank You karma gamer
for that sub appreciate it
queen bee - here comes 94 b5 first and
then 94 I'm assuming no yep I likey 5
yeah at this point I feel like it's
almost just Full Tilt's like psychology
at this point obviously Fabi just not
having his best day maybe bullet he he
shakes it off and gets a few more but at
this point hard to imagine a comeback
given how well LaVon is playing LeBron
is playing like a total monster and I
don't know if it's the Celtics Jersey
that he's sporting yeah or maybe this is
really all about sending a message to
Kawhi Leonard that the east of the East
is not for sale
oh 94 just taking any six that is
resigning though it's over over Red
Rover send a rook right over oh man oh
man I didn't know what to say at this
point because yes no it's it's tough
feels bad man feels bad to be Fabiano
the East is not for sale says Levon
Aronian and all the Celtics fans and
apparently his fake tan as he continues
to become more red by the midday don't
know what's going on with them maybe
someone has to turn off that light
before he turns into an Opel lupa it's
funny I was just thinking the same I
think that's so funny but he just shout
out to to Celtic Frost just gifted
moobot thanks for the gift Celtic Frost
yeah well Oompa Loompas are people too
as LaVon would remind us but at this
point Robert I don't even have much to
analyze but I am gonna bring you back on
just to ask you again to play coach
before we get to bullet give us your
final speech to Fabiana would you say
let's go get drinks or what's going on
how do you how are you how are you
describing this I guess they're
describing as well we're preparing for
World Championship match we are not
trying not to play as much speech just
because you need to focus in your
classical game but this is a really poor
showing unfortunately for Fabiano yeah
and you know I wish I had better advice
but just everything has been awful you
have bullet left to play it's sort of
meaningless when you're down how many
points is he down nine is dow dow
tonight will we even get nine bullet
games like how many ball games you play
uh somewhere between eight and ten yeah
you're right on average based on the
previous matches we've had some people
in the twitch chat and chess TV chat
asked how many games do you play
remember the format of the speech Estes
is unique in the sense that you're
racing against the game clock - you see
that clock right above Roberts head
right there right after those three
minutes we will take a small break and
then have bullet chess where we usually
enjoy what we see on the board between a
couple of north of 2780 players and
bullets so regardless of the match
result don't go anywhere
should be a lot of fun but yeah I agree
with you I think at this point you
remind Fabi the bigger picture likely
likely he's not in any position to come
back and win the match but um but okay I
mean what are you supposed to tell a
player who's down nine points has no
shot of winning you put you ask me to be
impossible questions like this you're
putting me on the spot here I'm nothing
to say yeah I'm not the eloquent coach
that you want me to be I'm not Steve
Kerr whoever said my voice sound like
Steve curves you're eloquent in my mind
okay and shout-out to Celtic Frost with
the last sub and snatch paedo
coming in love that guy snatch wow that
was that sounded weird I didn't at all
are you talking about the job with the
Brad Pitt movie most underrated role
what is a career in movie great movie
okay but this is an easy structure for
Mike to play you bring the pieces to the
kingside with a move like Knight g4 up
denied access but now that east six pawn
and the f4 square potentially weak so
again we're analyzing chess here to
learn enjoying the day Robert mentioned
already briefly that there's plenty of
more speed chess matches ahead I'm just
gonna remind everybody for those of you
who don't know join us unless actually
about twenty-four hours look at that
top-left corner hit Cara Nakamura versus
Ho Yifan will be taking place Thursday
evening it's an evening match at 5:00
p.m. Pacific as
Vaughn joins us from China so make sure
you're here on Thursday for the next big
match so are you talking to me because I
feel like I have to be here yeah you're
I didn't ask you
I don't you know you don't have a choice
you tell me yeah exactly but but
everybody else has a choice at least at
this point you know all right
interesting stuff with chief for what
black really wants here live Robert is
'if I've just to open up tactics on the
Jeep on maybe maybe the Vaughn could
play it rude aboot new oh bugger
called it 'if I've I like it I love it I
want some McLovin on the light squares
take G for an f3 anyway come on let's
call for blood
let's go Levon let's go only 20 seconds
left in the 300 and work out you take on
G flat a come on run at 5-4 a
white and just say thank you for all the
white squares so you give the piece back
and he deny my fork you would be 5
hanging here yep
found it you would deny me from some
good forking dirtiest Queen b6 check
would pick up that bishop but then the
e5 Bishop was hanging if you take on b5
right away Queen takes d5 check and then
I pick up either a 5 or okay you want
this no this looks like it could be a
good win a much-needed win for Fabiano
who knows maybe we see the most epic
comeback of all time with this win
carrying a bit of momentum for the
American into bullet but don't hope
don't hold out hope I Danny I'm just
messing with Artsakh minutiae on them
again the manage of the Armenia Eagles
the protest League he's saying that he's
very proud of LaVon blah blah blah then
he goes zabun on Jay Austin will also
crush the deed so we have some huge
Armenian loyalty by Artsakh Manuka in
there
and in this game well this one looks all
but over
and so the time is up for the
three-minute portion of this so LaVon
plays Bishop before you just take with
the pawn on d4 throw a rook on to the e5
square just feels you gotta Brooke on to
the e1 square and just feel good man
Fabi hasn't had many feel-good moments
today so he needs this one
yeah yeah this isn't take the pawn if
Bishop c6 you have rook a5 with tempo so
you don't lose em 3 wait this Queen a 5
for citrate ofstuff
25 might force Queen b6 yeah let's see
oh there's there goes the ambulance
again oh please Robert where do you live
again I live in Manhattan where's your
where's your former roommate from you
want well isn't anybody made you of my
roommate from Argentina emo like maybe
just an Argentine flag hey didn't have a
question yeah you know my former friend
named Daniel oh yeah what is his last
name
they were disky I said I liked Danya
he's done yet there's this guy named
Daniel Frank only my mother called me
Daniel okay I'm Danny so I don't know
who you're talking about but alright
anyway here comes rookie six Bobby's
gonna get this one oh I love this
comment by Effy Effy czar says Robert
lives in GTA Grand Theft Auto that's
right he's trapped in the video game so
that's some black mirror stuff I don't
know if you watched that show but okay
so you know I can't handle horror shows
well it's great I've told you not to
bring that up on camera I get scared
easily this is over
I mean Shia LaBeouf scares me dude come
on well Shia LaBeouf is an interesting
individuals rook b7 alright Bobby come
on
put it away baby Brooke e6 check g6
checks don't think bring the other rook
into e6 let's go let's do it
so he'll be down eight points after this
or should we not call it too soon okay
rook g6 rook other east six I was
highlighting on the analysis board I'm
sorry everybody we know how you love
those highlights okay there's no use of
the check King hides on h2 at some point
white shouldn't even be in a rush to
take h6 just trying to overwhelm this
Queen from f8 really even moves like
Queen a3 you're interesting here
followed by taking everything with check
and then trade back that's what I have
six just wins in the spot rook f6 also
wins here on the spot picking between
flavors
is what you can do when you go to
baskin-robbins there you go
also what you can do when you're easily
winning which Fabiano has not had many
of those opportunities today but looks
like he's getting this one as we see the
Levon scratches his nearly oompa-loompa
head Fabiano trying to find the right
technique I'm actually failing to see
the knockout blow to where's the
knockout blow
there isn't one which is why I didn't
want him to take on h6 so quickly but
this is still winning out with only
pawns White has a clue too many that's
how many Queen even every pawn I was
gonna say do you do you put the Queen
recision we're at some point you might
even just take on f4 take on f4 with the
night just to open up the king because
there may be some sort of checks that
win a loose rook like this but okay okay
nice work nice work the real issue is
though is that this Knight is not in
play at that point was Knight takes up
four and G five the right way I think
Knight takes f4 and g5 should be played
at some point LaVon was so close to
flagging there isn't one set up any one
time okay well he struggles to defend
that one you and I struggle to to keep
this match close but not really our
fault you're keeping things close with
that facial hair we're gonna be right
back to talk about what Fabiano Caruana
should probably do in bullet to make
this thing more of a match Robert don't
go anywhere the score board reads reads
a tough one right now for the American
but there are 9,000 of you tuned in on
twitch and chest comm TV where ever you
may be joining us from thank you for
your support thank you for that last sub
right as I say that this has been a very
entertaining day albeit a rather
surprising one Robert if we look at the
the stats as we've said coming into the
match Levon Aronian was a favorite but
not by this much as as a switch says not
like this not like this yeah you know
you the stats back Levon Aronian up a
lot of the fans
Tim in the fantasy bracket I did pick
Fabi precisely because I knew that
people will be picking LaVon but LaVon
backing it up you know he he trash talks
a pretty mean game but he also plays
some great chess and well with just the
bullet portion left eight game lead
yeah there's no chance that LaVon is not
winning this one well we'll see if
Fabiana can prove us wrong both the math
and the host would be proven wrong but
yeah we said to agree that the the
Celtic pride the luck the luck of the
Irish is on LaVon side today he will be
winning his first match in speeches
championship history as you said partner
he lost two of the closest matches we've
ever had he's been do and today he he
brought everything against Fabiano the
bullet has begun the clock is ticking on
Fabiano thirty minutes to prove a
comeback or not and regardless of what
happens here we will be back in less
than fifty two hours for a car Nakamura
vs. holy faun
but yeah I've been all of on all day
let's see if we get some exciting bullet
games yeah I mean it's interesting that
LaVon continues to play E for so I don't
know if he's really and thinking about
considering me for as a more permanent
ship or just a just a blitz a blitz
approach right just blitz maps knees
using it and right now all the pieces
are traded off LaVon puts a piece in f5
okay pawns trucks are slightly more
favorable for black a white of black
okay yeah I was gonna say I like I was
gonna say the position is slightly more
favorable to white in my mind because of
the control over the center but oh yeah
GG pawns so slightly better for black
Queen e2 not only a blunder right Don I
throw my weight what Queen e2 I could
have moved my knight from d3 but ya know
that looked and then I bring my Knight
to e4 after I thought that I just put my
Queen into the action okay here y should
just play b3
no no 90 Knight g4 defends the a pawn
agent vertically everybody by unleashing
the Queen's threat on the d6 night so
maybe gg5 Knight f6 check
Kingi seven-night h 5 Chuck King G 6
maybe maybe king of feet here that way
you have to trade queens the campaign
you have to close out I didn't see King
g7 runs into Queen takes d6 for town on
e8 yeah that's a problem yeah that's why
he can't play King g7 okay so now 94
here III he had to e3 there a missed
opportunity to play III to ruin White's
pawn structure was still better here but
there was a really good shot with III
cuz you couldn't take the knight as the
poet promoted okay so with a
three-on-two but only really a slight
advantage to to claim with it likely
this should be a draw I say three on two
because the pollens are doubled
obviously but yes it's really three on
three which is why best place should be
a draw routing for some bullet blunders
apparently Hikaru hey Kardos says that
g5 is uh is good for black I don't know
exactly what her car was saying in the
chest comm TV chat but Hikaru Nakamura
the one the only is hanging out with us
on chest comm TV shout-out to him
well now g4 check and fall by 94 there's
no way for white to keep hold of both
see end you can play King d3 and
currently you're holding both but likely
just a matter of time before zoogs log
and I'll play h5 is black and just kind
of hold you at bay hey Carl giving you
some love Robert says you saw the e3
idea which was awesome even though Fabi
missed it hey Thank You Cara where is he
talking right into the just comp TV chat
just being awesome being Hikaru
appreciate that and right now okay so c5
check kick that King back yes five five
use back but then you have no entry
point so how it had a little annoying
about but if i yeah i guess i go to h4
no h4 you have to go g3 is black but
yeah i don't think there's any way in
yet so they just agreed to a draw so
perhaps this III idea about you was
indeed Bobby on his last chance and he's
running out of chances
obviously with with time ticking away
here yeah you know I'm just moving a
mile a minute just trying to figure
things out 26 minutes on the total game
clock don't go anywhere remember
after the match obviously we'll talk to
both players and get their thoughts on
what went down here today maybe we'll
show some some of the best photo shops
and and announce who our one-year
diamond membership winner will be okay
so here with the white pieces father
gets absolutely nothing out of the
opening the effect maybe he just gets a
worse position that's what I'm seeing
here the d4 pawn is vulnerable the
bishop on g7 attacks upon that there
should be two only is the defense of pew
so so far things going lavon's way
completely this is just great for black
yep
and we just saw look like a grandmaster
floating behind Fabiano they're walking
you this other room yep a grandmaster
who also is a popular streamer christian
korilla yep the count the count himself
people spam in those hikaru emotes hey
Carlos got some of the best emotes
worthy of a subscription to his twitch
channel if you're not
he's got the Eric Hansen with a bib in
his mouth because he adopts Eric Hansen
regularly he's they've they've got some
of the emotes of the things that Carlos
says very often you know and right now
this looks to be six I like that village
be six the bishop on b4 is sort of stuck
right now he for and b3 are gonna be
problems yeah so he's just gonna give up
the b3 pawn for what what's his uh for
hope and making a drop like trying to
move your queen in those things to e8
yeah there goes there's always hope
there actually isn't always hope that's
a you know but okay there's still hope
now even though black is up upon Queen
d8 Czech 55 don't do it made on h1 so
almost almost mated titled my
autobiography she's queen e6 now at some
point Queen a7 oh no he picks up the
pawn should just be a draw now about
Queen D no Queen d1 Queen dy thinks of
every
- ah aha and d4 is also hanging in some
wine where's the mate though okay he
gets out with g4 Levon plays f5 that's a
nice move threatening f4 everybody
that's a big problem for the white king
now this looks like it's Bishop f6 with
the division of six threatens Queen h1
and Queen takes oh okay I would have
played Bishop f6 first but looks like
this is queen sv6 right whoa
f4 check when's the Queen at four check
King H three 6s three is mate Fabiano
shrugs Atlas Shrugged the world is on
his shoulders going up against Magnus
Carlsen and right now this isn't the
best the best showing for for the World
Championship challenger so the the
French returns boy oh I did just see
that Hikaru is giving Levon a shout out
calling tricky laughs and you love Rosie
so maybe you're just trying to scout out
some potential competition here yeah
well if Vaughn wins this match and I'm
saying if with it being all but
mathematically over everybody a reminder
that we talked about Hikaru's next match
but Levon will be playing the winner of
onigiri and chakra our mama Gaurav now I
saw a question earlier in the twitch
chat Robert about why is it that Fabiana
LaVon are playing in the first round
well first of all note that every
matchup is tough and literally since the
beginning of this tournament there's
been matchups like you know Fabiano MVL
and I mean there's always been insanely
good first round matchups I mean one
year we had a row naeun versus Grichuk
in the first round right so I don't
think it's fair to say that this is not
a matchup that happens in a tournament
where you have a bunch of the world's
best super GM's but to note the reason
the pairings are they are but they are
at the bracket you can see is because
chess calm ratings were used to seed the
tournaments and that that means that the
players who had the highest ratings on
chess calm as of July 10th had the
higher seedings that's why though I
think one of the most lopsided
first-round match
chips Robert if we bring up that bracket
I mean what's your what's your vote for
the most lopsided first round I'm gonna
go giri Mahmoud Yara that's definitely
one that is kind of fun to see because
of the chest comm ratings what do you
think I just saw Bobby played rotates g3
eyes what to mention and that sacrifice
is open but uh the lopsided matchup it's
hard to say because Gary and Mahmoud
Jarvan Gary being the favorite I think
is strange but of course Nakamura versus
how a fan is that's just right you know
hey car is the heavy favorite to win it
all so that's gonna be the most lopsided
matchup and I would say second after
that is probably what you well I guess
what I didn't mean lopsided in the sense
that that giri or chakra RR or Mammadov
are heavy favorites I meant sort of a
surprising first round pairing oh god
yeah definitely no definitely Hikaru
Hikaru over you fawn is probably this no
one wants to be in Yvonne's shoes that's
for sure yeah I agree with that
well Fabi played the sack you thought of
but is it gonna be enough how many pawns
is yeah he's got a few one two
it's now five on two pawns yeah this is
should be sufficient so d4 here open up
that Bishop wait what's he doing with
this Queen
Levon is resourceful like he's just
coming for the black king now wait I
feel like White's not gonna lose this
game yeah something something really
crazy is happening under time pressure
here with both Kings wide open I think
either side could lose with a single
move King d5 what is that 97 check right
nice e7 King c5 you know it
Oh 96 oh he had 96 but he doesn't go for
it
look at his King on e7 what a wind's
coming to d6 so Queen e6 check Wow look
at this this is ridiculous a single
second increment has Fabiano living on
the edge he's done hanging night now yep
came back to d8 no I told you why I was
gonna win yeah this is just crazy this
is crazy stuff for Fabiano today
definitely definitely not as best your
queen c1 check probably the queen a6
also does the trick because two ladies
are better than one when it comes to
chess the inclusion there yeah important
important inclusion there and I can say
that at this point with a 10 game lead
and a borderline adoption on the table
right now Levon Aronian is on his way to
the second round in the speech Chess
Championship we're under the 20 minute
mark still 7,000 of you with us here
amazing turnout today for our first
speech a first official speech this
championship match of the year we've had
a knockout tournament we've had the
knockout that's right we've had the open
tournament but Levon Aronian setting the
tone for today's for this year's
speeches championship with it with a big
victory
yeah it's said attorneys up ten games
against someone who's number two in the
world that yep as decisive as it really
could get here and for Fabiano you just
have to be disappointed the game hasn't
gone the way you
like he's been struggling he said early
on he was competing well he won the
first game of the match it's easy to
forget that fact but ever since then
it's been all Levon and well
Levon came to win he is gonna win and
just very impressive display by him
absolutely
shout out to Ed Vetter I see you there
number-one fan I see there I still see
fabi's fro that's also something I see
FYI yep
yeah he's shrinking in his chair but his
fro still looking large and in charge
over here so what's going on g54 Caruana
looking good yeah okay Brooke h7 gonna
force the h-file Simplification at some
point we're looking to make a move like
g5 happen well I thought I should've
done it before it now looks a little bit
to a lady kind of the structure looking
yeah better later for black now because
this G pawn is is weak and there's not
really many other weak pawns on the
board I think probably g5 will be met by
f5 in most positions yep
which makes g5 less attractive c4
sit tight this is the kind of game that
could eat two more minutes off the total
game clock just now Black is just much
better here yeah and and can just sort
of play for two results for the next I
don't know time to go get a snack I'll
be back in like 90 seconds or even
longer I'll be back in five minutes this
game will still be going yeah thank you
oh wait actually there's a tactic there
that both players missed that instead of
kt8 there's night h3 I think that I mean
I was kind of waiting for that it's the
sort of the benefit of the King beyond
the e2 square nut bag okay so now night
h3 again okay he's missing the idea with
night h3 but that's alright
yeah night 899 age 3 everybody if you
take it the bishop takes she for forking
the King at night but ok there uh go
back now in men h3 plate at age 3
they're not they're not into the forking
and but hey Carlos still given you mad
prod saying Robert is seeing everything
today I mean it's the glasses are extra
sharp I got money
Lenalee them finally I've been telling
you do that I essentially use Windex oh
no there you go yeah Windex cures
everything
ok now came back to age 6 I think you
I'm not sure you can actually stop this
nice 3 plan well you don't feel better
can't you to do that
well as I predicted though regardless of
the result of this game it's taking how
many minutes off the game clock right
now let's take a look back up c8 and ho
live minutes off the game clock since
when this game started almost okay a
gentlemen's draw actually nearly a 50
move draw with how many moves they they
wasted their Lev misses night h3 and
fails to win that again yep that's why
you know when you're facing a bishop you
want to put your king on the opposite
color of that bishops just so you don't
walk into things like maybe h3 okay so
there you go another pro tip from Robert
Pro chip from mr. Hess let's try to
analyze some bullet let's do what
Nesbitt deunov said actually even
mentioned how crazy bullet is but we'll
try to have an analysis board here and
stay with it so blacks should just play
Bishop g7 and Castle here what's going
on
yeah you take on d3 which he ends up
doing play if you bury Bishop d6 because
your vision doesn't need to be on this
diagonal face net c3 pawn official nd
six gives you hope in the future and
there he goes K of putting your Queen on
the diagonal as well - yeah Brennan some
checkmating ideas so Queen e7 check you
could have just thrown that in to force
a queen exchange probably creative which
is good for black and now Knight I want
to go Knight e4 and 9 h5 both those
options look pretty tempting is the idea
of Knight h5 to go to f4 okay there's no
there's no g4 shots on that
well metaphor is the 90 to check big
okay yeah big time yeah so here okay
Bishop g5 for whites I think White's
gotten out of this gotten out of the
bind temporarily but Bishop takes up
three might come so I should bring a
knight to d2 as yesterday sevens
actually hanging here that's not the
point because if black plays a simple
move like Bishop e7 just trying to deal
with the tactics white just might gobble
the pollen yep and f3 is close to
trapping that Bishop not quite yet but
it's very close you so okay wait what
so f3 Bishop of a bishop c2 is an option
so that that's why the Bishop stays
alive now Bishop CC is a good okay
Bishop to see to take c6 no don't take
with the palm why didn't take with the
pawn giving him the open file and once
he wants a five he wants he vibe that's
why can you take on e6 now yep yep game
oh my gosh just frustrated Fabiano
laughs laughs it off yet again losing a
game that he shouldn't have specifically
that Queen takes c6 was definitely much
better there this looks bad
so does look bad LaVon playing the the
push and Harry Harry's getting involved
on the h-file are you turning into Simon
wounds no I just you know thinking of
things to say and sometimes I don't
think about what I'm saying
it's a obscene a therapist about it told
you that okay well that was the
confidence I didn't want to reveal it on
the air but you know it's your
prerogative you can do really you can
air out your dirty laundry I just did
laundry thank you very much
you do what you should that's why you're
wearing the chest con pollo exactly
fresh out the wash yep so let's see can
black sacrifice and g5 it's I love
sacrificing exchanges for those of you
who are not familiar
oh he does it Petrosian here we go the
Queen the Queen takes 95 I mean I'm a
fan of sac in the exchange when it's
good and this looks pretty good here too
like we said the Petrosian Armenian
school of chess coming out the one's
gonna lavon's gonna win this game in
fine fashion he's gonna put another pony
on e5 which block c4 keeps the bishop
bad and probably g5 will fall at some
point if Queen d2 I think I'm just
trading on d4 and then taking g5 right
yep that looks pretty yes straight
forward now Knight G to e5 right GD v
gets a temple on the Queen can I even
have just played Queen takes g5 and
giving me the f7 squared there's no real
need to does interesting no need to
though as you said and here don't even
annex Queen h2 he'll move the rook
develop your bishop maybe to c6 where it
hits efore or just come into H 3 g5 now
and just keep pushing you up you can't
go Queen f6 as Queen e2 Neji forecheck
wins the Queen I have six ouch Tina's
nowhere to go so Queen H - yes - King up
Knight g4 king e1 then Queen takes g3
perhaps Bishop h3 is coming now yeah he
plays it Knight g4 looking for h6 same
idea this is like this is one of the
most lot surprising lopsided matches
we've ever had in Sec history Brooke f6
check is just winning here can't take it
because ninety 4 and Livan plays that
this ship G for looks like a pretty good
idea Bishop g2 is a free piece honest
vicious recheck wheezes or check
Queenie for me no it's not me Knight g4
check Wentz the Queen Dale okay at this
point Bobby's just hoping for the end of
the day that's the kind of that's the
kind of day he's having just hoping for
it to all come to an end we have E for
knight c6 but LaVon is ruthless he's not
messing around with bullet openings like
we said this is a lavon's day to make a
statement about he is here to win it all
as he told our our own mic line in an
interview before the match started that
you know he doesn't he doesn't plan on
not winning this year's SEC I'm no
Vacarro here's that oh yeah you know and
that's a yeah give a shout outs a car
because he of course has come very very
close to winning the SEC but loss of
mecca's Carlson in fourth mashes Magnus
of course being the piece that we all
know and appreciate but here without
Magnus this year it's Hikaru's you know
the circuit cardiac can will have
something to say about this but Levon
Aronian really impressing his opening
match Queens night out wandering in the
chest TV chat why didn't live on play
like this in the candidates well I don't
know different tournament a car versus
Lev has as good a chance as anyone
yes smiley face I don't know if a car
means that but it is a compliment to
LaVon for sure yeah I mean LaVon is is
as we said I mean obviously it's our job
to talk and provide context and you know
hopefully hopefully you know make it a
entertaining and educational but we
mentioned that LaVon has lost two of the
closest matches in Sec history certainly
one of the first-round exits that who
knows what he would have done if he had
gotten farther in the event right yep so
now adds Sergei Levin myself flip a coin
I wonder what he thinks about mom and
Joe no mention of him and mama Jarvis
never played the format before so I'm
curious on the
but this Knight takes f7 was really nice
by the way Knight takes h7 just bring
the other rook over to f1 now so Brooke
c3 actually just wins the bishop ah and
if Czech Bishop of one or Brooke f1 you
drink f1 for school you're winning a
piece and maintaining the attack Fabiano
resigns again and we have are we getting
in the realm of adoption how many games
in a row is LaVon won if I'm gonna made
one draw somewhere because he's five and
a half points okay this is just this is
a an impressive performance to say the
least and and Fabiano on Full Tilt yeah
no it's just one of those days where you
lose a couple games you just continue
losing it happens to the best host we
saw it you have an MDL right yep played
against a card the start of the match
was pretty interesting when all of a
sudden he started losing every single
game that's credit to the players are
winning in this case Levon Aronian but
right it's not Fabi on his day at all
he's really struggling here for sure and
shout-out to our beast in the chest comm
chat because our be said that we went to
the same high school so awesome on that
front have no idea who you are but sweet
all the water you ever got got to
represent alright so in this position
this looks like a Levon Aronian set up
with on 85 kb6 get that about
being keto it what do you really want
for blacks for that night from d7 to c5
but what you want from white that Bishop
over moves from c5 my knight will go to
e3 two f5s now the e4 pawn is a clear
target Bishop e3 White's gonna prepare
the plan though that you talked about
and the question is once you get there
can you can you start launching a King
side attack Queen e2 one funny idea is
maybe you want to relocate the bishop
from d3 to C 2 and B 3 and bring it to a
new diagonal
okay you may not have time for that
takes under four oh I thought he would
take with the e pawn and gang up on e4
but G pawn slightly surprising no not
for you no I'm trying to figure out
what's going on here because I am
surprised and now this makes sense from
Fabiana he's trying to bring us Knights
they have five squares yes no you guys
be careful
efore pawn because if you do something
with g4 rook taste d3 comes immediately
those exchange sacs our team attic and
straightforward here rook g8 I think
White's gonna play okay Bishop c4 if you
win g4 is a sacrifice in the horizon you
have at chickens Bishop c4 Knight a5
bring the other night in to f3 at some
point in a 5 falls but if you add g4 now
what my white blacks does not age 5
season be careful about that as well
because your KH 2 is not safe really
though I mean there's these threats of
knight of three I think I can give up
efore 45 because f7 is is a target a lot
of positions
oh he sacks on d2 Petrosian coming out
again oh I think that's that's perfect
he's gonna undermine F 2 G 3 falls yep
Wow kid you know now it's just crushing
Queen c5 check G freeze falling Queen
takes e4 and we take c4 wins apiece
followed by 92 okay he's gonna win a
piece the old-fashioned way who needs
Forks o-m-g fabiano down 19 and a half
to five and a half and we're learning
the best margin of victory ever is 17
games and right now we're at 14 yeah I
believe it was by Magnus Carlsen over
Tigran Petrosian Tigran Petrosian I
think that was the the all-time record
in the SEC as far as margin of victories
we'll see
okay well feels bad rough day for
Fabiano only four minutes left but still
super interesting for us from the
perspective that Levon Aronian really
making a statement and setting the tone
for us to be excited about whoever he
plays whether it be Gary or Mahmoud
you're up in the next round can say that
I'm just a little speechless what's
going on right now yep yeah I want to
comment on the chest but I keep looking
at the scoreboard seeing 19 a half to
five and a half and it's it's hurting
it's really hurting for Fabi but okay we
just have a few more games left let's
continue focusing on the chest I guess I
must I must make myself get in that
mindset here and so nigh on g4 come into
e5 square trying to make use of the fact
that White has the two knights versus
bish one f5 so if these nice get traded
for example Knight takes d5 Knight takes
e5 you see a wonderful night outpost on
the e5 square yeah versus at Bishop
that's not a bad Bishop but still it can
never kick the night away the pawn on g5
came from the F the F file which means
you can't go f6 you take the night out
so right now
black contending the lockdown the
position eventually Bishop to e4 so
similarly things I'm at an e5 it's got a
great outpost well defended by pawns
this Bishop can go to e4 and try to stay
centralized and defendant so the g4 pawn
now is a bit of a target
it's a Queen h4 blacks go and g6 and I
think in this point of view Fischer
before did come h3 should be played by
white that's that's the reason why I
didn't want to put my bish 1.e4 because
I'm with my bishop and f5 if you play h3
and I capture you have to take with the
jeep on now with my official in E 4 you
can just take the rook put it back on g3
okay now put Queen I don't want to trade
up like Queen back to completing g3 I
sort of like Queen to f2 to go over of
g3 oh look at this
so now you're throwing pawn g4 in effect
I think it's on g4 is happening no
matter what
that was a clever little snake by LaVon
Queen h4 2g through the h2 mm-hmm
getting the Queen behind the brook and
here's g4 take on h5 looks as LaVon said
are as Hikaru said tricky tricky skin
complexion or tactics for LaVon yep so
I'm going to say now that's pretty
straightforward
yeah anything update because 97 was for
King the king and queen almost over
Bobby looks up and says when is it over
this should be the last game of the
match we will be joined by the players
right now still 5000 of you with us
despite the lopsided match here we
appreciate all of the support all those
who sub today all the donations
everything thanks for being here
last game the kind of the torture and
the sadness will end thankfully for Fabi
yeah but you know he can put the LaVon
hype you know Aronian hype I mean he
played like a monster today yeah just
total beast yep and a lot of respect for
him I've always liked LaVon a lot and
he's an amazing player and I'd love that
he showed his flexibility today he spent
many different openings yep he's be able
to play efore with white and we know him
and we love him as a great d4 in c4
player and over the board chest but
nowadays any efore to his repertoire
released in the speech s format it's
making things much more exciting and
making him harder to pin down and
prepare for and that's what we talked
about Dani
in the qualifier right Georg Meier is
much easier to prepare for them any
other players because he sticks to his
guns every game where as a player like
LaVon clearly mixing and matching
depending on this match situation it's
going very well for him thus far yep
absolutely and well said and we'll see
if that's something he continues at his
next match as Levon Aronian will be
moving on to face the winner between
onigiri and chakra our Mahmud you're off
so that won't be for a month and a half
two months or so so don't be in a huge
rush till that next round matchup goes
down with LaVon but maybe Fabiano ends
on a high note here with time officially
being up the match is over this is the
last game regardless of the result and
then we will have a quick chat with the
players before moving on yep and well I
don't even know what to ask Fabi I've
been trying to think about that we'll
see but for LaVon there's no way he
could have expected this so I am curious
how he's feeling after this demolition
yep well LaVon passed 3,000 at both
blitz and bullet as someone on Twitch
just pointed out so you know maybe
that's why he was so ruthless today
really wanted those 3,000 marks to let a
car oh no he's coming for him coming for
the highest ratings he was upset about
his seating you know he didn't realize
that it was by chess calm ratings and
then he's I'm underrated is what he was
saying
2850 or whatever he was to start the
match what did he start this match at I
don't know someone will have to check
into that look at the game archive
history but it certainly wasn't anywhere
close to where he finished now and we're
learning that Carlsen verso was an
18-game margin so ah that's right Magnus
Magnus was really in rare form on that
day and Wesley Wesley was not so
something with c7 check now no doesn't
work c 17d seven bishop d5 trade bishops
in d5 rook d7 after that keep your C
pawn yeah it's gonna be choking one that
Fabiano can push for a win but what was
that okay switching
switching to the kingside and free move
and quickly LaVon really down to the
increment everybody yep but now this
endgame is much easier to hold than what
we were looking at before yeah because
the three on two if you trade one pair
of rooks theoretical draw if you keep
the rooks on the board well you're gonna
have a hard time doing anything with
your pawn f2 indeed right and this is
not the way to do it from Fabi
he should have moved his rook f1 over to
the a farmtruck playbook a7 with his
work on f3 we're gonna have three is
very strong now he's oh he almost flag
Lamaze in flag
oh-oh-oh point eight week removed
removed just enough to gain some
increment back and I when she LaVon
moving on cameras are clearly he's like
yeah a jury per se but he's down oh he
goes for the Mel slip okay
last last try to uh
just swindle his opponent but not enough
Fabiano ends the match today with a win
despite the despite the tough day and we
are joined quickly by both players
Fabiano and LaVon can you both hear us
yeah yeah great you mind um lowering
your camera just a little bit so we can
see you both a little more surely well
it goes without saying I was a amazing
match today great play for you LaVon
your thoughts on on how the day went you
were obviously seem to be feeling good
in pretty good form and your thoughts
about what went down here yeah I think
Fabiana wasn't playing his opening so
that's why you know when you're playing
positions that end up too familiar you
know he's trying to hide his preparation
or for Backhouse yes well obviously we
speculated about that exact point
Fabiano clearly as LaVon said not not
necessarily your best day but maybe not
by accident you were you were not
playing your regular repertoire you even
played some French openings I mean
Robert and I went had a field day with
your with your
choice of the French and the Benoni but
jokes aside obviously I know the match
didn't go the way you wanted but talk a
little bit about maybe the struggles
today and was it just hard to find your
form playing positions that you weren't
familiar with no I I mean I just got
very tilted at some point and I wasn't
really thinking about my moves first
especially in the opening I was playing
just very very quickly and not really
thinking about what I was doing and
usually getting very bad positions and
the few times I did get good positions I
I usually messed them up pretty quickly
so but at some point too it was just it
got very very very tilted which is never
a good thing in bowls yeah so it was
it's you it wasn't what is as much about
the the opening just kind of
psychologically frustrated with with
some of those close losses so makes
sense Robert well LaVon I have to ask
you so what is going on with the light
up there people kept asking if you're in
like a tanning salon or in a bar can you
explain this light behind you all right
I'll just move my camera a little bit so
you can see you see oh yeah do you see
the front yeah I love it and so you know
it's it's a musical stage I love it no
that explains what what kind of light
what kind of light do you expect at the
at home that also serves the purpose of
being a hangout for musicians well LaVon
you're you're moving on past the first
round for the first time in in your
speech Chess Championship career we were
talking about how of all players never
to make it past the first round you had
two of the best most exciting closest
matches and how excited are you for the
for the remainder of this tournament
knowing you will have the winner between
onigiri and Mahmud Yara how do you how
do you look up that at that matchup but
who would you rather face well I'm going
to as usual I'm going to root for my a
nice boy
I'm a big fan of his play so I would
love to meet and play against him but I
think chef Pierre is is a very tough
opponent so I still keep my fingers
crossed or Anish but we'll see we'll see
I I'm enjoying it I mean I didn't have
any drastic problems with my connection
so okay so far so good so far so luck
the luck of the Irish is with you there
as as you're sporting the Celtics Jersey
well Fabiana you had a lot of a lot of
fans today and a lot of support
regardless of the tough result everybody
looking forward to what's ahead for you
this year I know at this point you
probably just don't care about that but
last final thoughts we thank you for
being here and any any any secrets you
want to tell us
how's preparation going yeah it's going
well oh yeah unfortunately I'm not like
this really puts a dent in your and your
will to to look at chess anymore yeah at
least you want some sort of fight but
this was quite a disastrous match well
what is Christian cooking for you
tonight no idea well either way maybe
maybe a beer with your meal and forget
about it but we know it didn't go the
way you wanted to Fabiano but we really
thank you for being here
Livan wishing you the best of luck in
the next round
no no more silly questions besides your
predicted record for the Celtics next
year well winning the conference I mean
it's a start
all right Robert anything else well I
definitely want to go to NBA game now
with LaVon but I also have just
mesmerized by that performance and last
question after you LaVon you'd mentioned
in your interview with my client perhaps
jokingly that as long as you don't get
flagged you'd be good do you
specifically work on your bullet portion
because you were very impressive in that
time control in addition oh no no I
think I was really bad in bullet
but the thing is Fabiano had the
disasters blitz start so he can't
exploit it but if the match was closed I
knew that this is my weakness
and unfortunately a really dislike
playing bullet so I don't think it's
going to improve anytime soon
got it well regardless of whether
bullets your weakness you sent a message
here today a very a very nice victory
for you so congratulations Fabiano again
thank you we'll see you next year maybe
maybe as world champion by the time next
year's event starts we wish you the best
of luck in November and thank you both
once again thanks thank you alrighty
then well Robert as we as we take a look
at the at the bracket here and hopefully
we get a move on on the Russian stream
too right now that's right LaVon LaVon
is here and we are you and I will be
dropping out of this call actually the
bond you're still there right yeah okay
I think I think our our show will be
coming to an end here momentarily but
we're gonna mute ourselves and let you
um let you join the Russian call and
thanks again and congratulations again
great thank you